et judiciaires manière
14h47 figaro live bonjour bienvenue nous
sommes en direct c'est un baptême du feu
elisabeth bornes des sens seul dans
l'arène de quel bois effet la première
ministre aura t-on enfin des réponses
alors qu'elle semble presque
transparente depuis sa nomination toutes
les lumières seront braqués sur elle à
15 heures elle fera face aux députés la
majorité d'entre eux ne sont pas dans
son camp mais il faudra bien prononcé le
traditionnel discours de politique
générale bonjour guillaume tabard
bonjour rédacteur en chef et
éditorialiste politique au figaro merci
d'être ici alors je vous lis ce matin
guillaume dans votre contrepoint et je
vous lis précisément l'histoire le
prouve ce type de prestation suscite en
général beaucoup d'attentes avant et
beaucoup de déception après on en fait
trop sur discours de politique générale
ou si si c'est très utile attention ne
me demandez pas mon direct non justement
là tout l'intérêt va être d'écouter ce
que va dire elisabeth bornes disons
c'est vrai que là la solennité de
l'exercice première intervention du chef
du gouvernement de la chef du
gouvernement en l'occurrence devant une
assemblée une nouvelle en général aussi
le coup d'envoi d'un nouveau mandat
présidentiel comme comme c'est le cas
fait que cet événement suscite beaucoup
d'attentes on attend faire des
précisions sur ce que ça rend bien ce
rôle action du gouvernement pendant
pendant cinq ans bon ensuite quand je
dis que fomc ya beaucoup de déception
générale après c'est que l'exercice il
reste qu'il est c'est que ça reste un
discours oui très solennelle souvent
c'est lourd oui puis surtout qu'ils
étaient pris entre deux contradictions
parce que soit ce discours n'est qu'une
énumération de mesures d'un planning
bien voilà on va faire ceci puis on va
faire cela souvent après andy ben
finalement ça manquait de souffle y a
pas de vision mais si inversement
le chef du gouvernement se contente de
quelques généralités ou d'un cadrage
globale va dire ben alors à quoi ça
manquait de précision on sait toujours
pas ce qu'il veut faire donc à cette
ligne de crête que chacun
d'eux doit tenir voilà et donc la
curiosité réside dans le fait qu'à
chaque fois on se demande comment le
nouveau ou la nouvelle occupante de
matignon va ça va sentir et donc à cet
effet curiosité préalable ou non tout va
dépendre excessivement de ce qu'elle va
dire exactement vous réagissez sur
lefigaro.fr sur youtube sur twitch on
essaie de décrypter ce qui va se dire
d'ici une petite dizaine de minutes mais
d'abord on fait un petit tour par
l'assemblée nationale avec vincent
rosereau vincent vous êtes sur place ça
s'agite autour de vous est ce que
l'hémicycle se remplit progressivement
attendait d'ailleurs la sonnette qui
vient de retentir et les députés sont
appelés à être sur place à l'assemblée
nationale je sais pas si vous entendez
bien ce que je dis ça fait de plus d'une
demi heure trois quart d'heure qu'ils
arrivent au compte gouttes on a vu
sandrine rousseau julien bayou raquel
garrido bruno gollnisch gilles legendre
arriver petit à petit à noter une chose
un petit happening qui a eu lieu avant
cette séance devant l'assemblée par les
insoumis il y avait là plusieurs députés
ont soumis qui ont animé un faux mariage
entre les rebelles et le rn le but c'est
de montrer l'enterrement du front
républicain ceux ci voulaient montrer
on
peut le voir sur les images de clémente
qui m'accompagnent
[Musique]
et pendant un discours de politique
générale ou la non généralement c'est
assez calme
elisabeth bost rares peuvent être
regardés pendant pas par exemple les
députés du rassemblement national à lors
du rassemblement national je ne pense
pas ce qu'on voit bien que toute la
stratégie même les mutuelles le la le
comportement naturel des députés du
rassemblement national c'est plutôt de
dire nous sommes là pour jouer le
respect des institutions
ils seront vraiment respectueux du
fonctionnement de l'assemblée d'emblée
on dit que ça sert à rien de voter une
motion de censure contre isabelle borne
en gros ce thème on est en désaccord
avec elle mais après tout celle qui
était désigné c'était à elle de de faire
ses preuves ils ne sont pas du tout dans
la logique de harcèlement dans laquelle
son talent inverse les les députés la
france a soumises qui on voit d'ailleurs
masse récent général puisque tous vont
voter la motion de censure l'aserc en
fait on voit que toute la gauche s'est
alignée sur la ligne radicale imposé par
par jean luc mélenchon un petit mot sur
l'évocation du mariage sert que les amh
ne m'interesse ne manque vraiment pas
d'air parce que en gros le fait que le
rn ne vote pas sa motion de censure il
va y est c'est la preuve d'une collusion
entre le rn et la majorité alors qu'ils
n'ont pas mêler leurs voix ensemble les
mêmes insoumis aurait été très content
que l'est que le rn vote sa propre sont
censurés là il n'aurait pas parlé d'un
mariage entre eux et le rassemblement
national donc on est bien que depuis
démissionné depuis le début de cette
législature il ya de la part des
insoumis donc de la gauche en général
d'ailleurs une mauvaise foi qui est
attaqué la stratégie carrossée sait qu
on dise crédibilise tout on y est
presque par ont quelque part on sabote
le par avance le travail de cette
assemblée mais c'est assez rigolo parce
que justement la gauche depuis le début
veux dire c'est nous l'opposition c'est
nous c'est nous et le rassemblement
national qui a besoin d'être un parti
d'opposition l'ue a besoin aussi de
respectabilité donc ces deux stratégies
très différentes des deux côtés oui mais
c'est pas je ne suis pas surpris que ça
se réalise en surprise c'est ce qui
depuis le début avait décrété qu'il y
avait un camp du bien et un conte du mal
et que le rn était le seul parti à
obtenir appartenir au camp du mal la
réalité c'est qu'on a un parti que jour
d'hui bazouges le jeu des institutions
le race noire nationale et qu'on n'a de
l'autre une gauche qui est sur des
positions non seulement radical que ce
après tout chacun est libre d'avoir
l'opposition en politique qu'il est le
sien mais alors des députés le bompard
de la france info qui va jusqu'à
contester la légitimité de l'élection
parce que bien sûr il ya le maquereau a
subi un revers aux élections
législatives au sens il n'a pas obtenu
de majorité absolue mais les insoumis
oublie de dire que celui qui reste et de
loin le premier groupe à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le groupe renaissance le
gouvernant la république et que ce n'est
pas un groupe qui fait 74 députés suit
la france a soumises qui peut dire moi
j'ai faim je suis légitime parce que je
suis l'opposition alors qu'eux mêmes ne
sont que le troisième groupe de cette
assemblée allez on revient sur elizabeth
dans alors j'ai des indiscrétions
guillaume sur ce qui pourrait se dire
que dans ce discours avec deux mots qui
reviennent qui devrait revenir souvent
ensemble et bâtir une fois qu'on a dit
ça on est bien avancé c'est pas mieux la
serre que oui certains comme toujours
pour comprendre la force d'un discours
il faut voir si l' inverse a un sens non
ensemble on n'imagine pas dire va tout
détruire et on va le faire en ordre
dispersé
donc voilà comme ça vous avez donc si
c'est effectivement les éléments de
langage données données par matignon
avant ce discours n'est pas on est bien
pas bien avant ces femmes ont pu tourner
on est bien avancé ce qui compte c'est
de dire concrètement quelles sont les
réformes sur lequel le gouvernement va
s'engager ou du mois va tenter de
proposer à l'assemblée ce que une chose
est de dire nous prenons acte que cette
assemblée plurielle et qu'il va falloir
travailler tous ensemble qui va falloir
trouver des compromis ça c'est une chose
c'est de la méthode il en faut mais
ensuite pour trouver des compromis
encore faut-il qu'ils aient une
proposition de base et cette profession
de base que pour l'instant on a du mal à
entendre ou à comprendre et sur lequel
on attend prioritairement
il y avait deux bornes 14h54 vous voyez
les députés qui progressivement entre
dans l'hémicycle pour écouter ce
discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth bornes une heure une heure
et quart ans à peu près ça la norme
comment faire pour que ce ne soit pas
ennuyeux qu'est ce qui pourrait nous
surprendre comment elle pourrait nous
surprendre les abeilles bornes écoutez
je pense que le pire c'est de jouer un
rôle de composition non gens c'est à
dire j'en lis cobas r que d'essayer de
2,2
d'avoir un style qui n'est pas le sien
avec eux il est bas demande elle a son
style qui a un style assez aux seniors
dont certains peuvent quelques rides
austère bon ceni un bien mis à mal c'est
ce qu'elle est ce cola dupont aignan qui
rentrent dans l'est mais celle ci si
elle se mettait à dire bah va jouer je
vais vous raconter quelques quelques
plaisanteries jusque sous les monts
poches pleines et secours jean pierre
raffarin avait fait ce qu'on avait
appelé ses fameuses raffarinade la whey
la la la la route est droite mais la
pente est forte et cetera bon c'était le
style de jean perrin d'avoir cessé
formule qui est quelqu'un qui était
ensuite commenté saleh passe-t-il les
habits de bornes donc je pense si pour
casser ce côté austère et décidé de
changer de style ça tomberait à côté et
elle commettrait une erreur de
communication mais une fois encore nous
ont pas trop attention à ton devoir dans
quelques minutes maintenant comment
comment elle va être devant les buts et
alors devant les députés puis je lis
aussi ce matin dans le journal face à
ces ministres l'autorité de bornes déjà
fragilisés ce papier de tristepin kino
molle alors je lis un plus proche d'elle
au tout premier plan elle pourra aussi
apercevoir les applaudissements plein
d'arrière pensées des poids lourds de
son propre gouvernement le maire
darmanin lecornu est-ce que là aussi
peut-être avant de parler aux français
avant de parler à l'ensemble de des
députés qui représentent le peuple de
france elle parle surtout à sa majorité
pour dire c'est moins la patronne est ce
qu'elle peut prendre le lead si j'ose
dire cet après midi alors c'est pas
l'objet de ce discours parce que levier
ce discours c'est effectivement de 2,2
dévoilé la feuille de route du
gouvernement il ya même pas d'enjeu de
majorité à obtenir puisque apparemment
vraiment où elle ne demande pas le vote
de confiance leur expliquer nous
d'ailleurs l'autre de confiance que
c'est pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
alors le gouvernement à tout moment peut
demander un vote de confiance sur une
déclaration dont caen sur un discours de
politique générale il n'y a pas tenu
beaucoup de communistes l'ont fait en
entrant en fonction tous ne l'ont pas
fait et s'il ne le fait pas et bien
l'opposition à la liberté de déposer une
motion de censure normalement c'est ce
qu'a choisi de faire la france a
soumises bon dos car pas de vote de
confiance et on sait bien que la motion
de censure ne sera voté que par les 152
députés de la gauche donc elle ne sera
pas adoptée donc à aucun suspense sur le
sur l'île sera propulsé les races est
apparue vieillissement donc voix et donc
sa majorité il n'a pas besoin d'eux
aujourd'hui le dollar soudé parce
qu'elle n'a pas elle n'a pas se conter
dans les urnes en revanche je pensais
bien que dans le leadership c'est ça oui
mais la poisse ans et surtout aux
français qu'elle doit dire voilà ce
qu'on va faire pendant cinq ans parce
que vous pensez en tout cas pendant
l'année qui vient dans la mesure où
depuis maintenant trois quatre mois on
n'a aucune idée de ce que le
gouvernement veut faire de ce
qu'emmanuel ma qu'on veut faire c'est ce
temps là qui commence à être un peu long
et on a plutôt envie de savoir
clairement quels sont les projets que le
moment va au moins tenter de faire
aboutir 14h57 trois petites minutes
avant le début théoriquement normalement
n'y a pas de retard sur ce genre doivent
d'événements d'elisabeth ben oui je sais
qu'il faut que je vous relâche de
tabarre j'ai juste une petite une
dernière question est ce qu'elle doit
égrainé une liste de propositions
est-ce qu'elle doit impulser une
dynamique générale comment elle doit
faire on rejoint la question du du casse
tête ni de ceux de cet exercice parce
que soient le fait une liste de courses
on va dire ben hassel c'est un catalogue
bon mais s'il ne le fait pas on va
pointer les les absences elle est
obligée de parler de quasiment de tous
les sujets fera qu elle parle bien sûr
d'emploi fracas parle de sécurité fera
qu'elle parle d'environnement fracas par
le transporte maintenant une part de la
ville beaucoup oui mais si un sujet dont
elle neutre non elle ne parle pas à 11
ira demande à ce jeu elle parle de 25
sujets et bien dira mais pourquoi
n'at-elle pas parler du 26e c'est le
toute la complexité d'exercice faut il
faut coché toutes les cases à la fois
d'où l'inévitable impression de
catalogue messahel n'y échappera pas
merci beaucoup guillaume tabard on va
faire un petit tour on va écouter ce qui
se passe à l'assemblée nationale et puis
si elisabeth bornes n'arrive pas d'une
minute à l'autre en ce qui devrait être
le cas on retrouvera vincent rejoindre
l'instant on écoute l'ambiance à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
à
autant
elisabeth bornes qui va donc arriver à
l'assemblée nationale y est lebron
peavey la présidente de l'assemblée
nationale qui va ouvrir cette session et
on va suivre tout ça tous ensemble un
discours qui devrait durer environ une
heure une heure et quart et puis
derrière on débrief tout ça avec les
réactions depuis l'assemblée nationale
avec carl meeus du figaro magazine il
sera avec nous on retourne sur les
images de l'assemblée nationale il ya
une drôle vive et la présidente de
l'assemblée qui ouvre cette session
elisabeth bornes face à son destin
peut-être c'est un baptême du feu de
quel bois et fait cet effet cette
première ministre eh bien on aura
peut-être enfin des réponses on est
partis à l'assemblée nationale
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés
en m'adressant à vous c'est à la france
que je parle
chacune de vos circonscriptions
porte une parcelle de notre histoire et
des défis qui s'ouvre devant nous
chacun de vos territoires
exprime une réalité de notre pays de ses
craintes et de ses espoirs
nous mesurons tous l'ampleur de la tâche
les français à protéger la république à
défendre notre pays a rassemblé la
planète à préserver
c'est le sens de l'action du président
de la république depuis cinq ans c'est
notre mission collective au gouvernement
comme sur ces bancs
avec vous avec tout le gouvernement avec
nos concitoyens nous réussirons je suis
déterminé
ces dernières semaines à quatre reprises
les françaises et les français se sont
exprimés
par le résultat des urnes
ils nous demandent d'agir et d'agir
autrement
par leur message ils nous demandent de
prendre collectivement nos
responsabilités nous le ferons
ensemble nous répondrons à l'écho de
l'abstention elle est le signe d'une
démocratie malade d'un désarroi de la
jeunesse d'une perte de confiance dans
notre capacité à changer des vies
ensemble nous répondrons à la demande
d'actions c'est celle qui s'exprime le
plus fortement dans le vote des français
nous ne pouvons pas décevoir
ensemble nous répondrons à l'exigence de
responsabilité
les français ont élu une assemblée sans
majorité absolue il nous invite à des
pratiques nouvelles un dialogue soutenu
à la recherche active de compromis
le contexte nous oblige la guerre en
ukraine aux portes de l'europe nous
rappelle combien la paix est fragile
les prix de l'énergie augmentent et nous
devons continuer à protéger les français
l'épidémie est toujours là et notre
vigilance doit rester total
l'urgence écologique se fait chaque
seconde plus pressante et nous avons un
devoir d'action
l'insécurité inquiète nos concitoyens et
brise encore des vies et des destins
nous devons le dire aussi dans les
dernières semaines du fait de la guerre
qui dure notre situation économique
s'est assombri nos perspectives de
croissance se dégradent les taux
d'intérêt augmentent quant à nos
finances publiques elles doivent
reprendre le chemin de l'équilibré
face à de tels défis le désordre et
l'instabilité ne sont pas des options
nous ne sommes peut-être pas d'accord
sur toutes les solutions mais nous avons
toutes et tous conscience de l'urgence
et de la nécessité d'agir
des français nous demandent de nous
parler plus de nous parler mieux est de
construire ensemble
nous répondrons
nous répondrons présent je veux qu'on
semble nous redonnions un sens et une
vertus au mot compromis depuis trop
longtemps oubliées dans notre vie
politique
le compromis ce n'est pas se
compromettre ses textes acceptés chacun
de faire un pas vers l'autre cela ne
signifie nullement l'effacement de nos
différences ou le renoncement à nos
convictions les clivages existent et ils
continueront à exister bâtir ensemble ne
signifie pas renoncer à son identité
la mienne vous le savez a pour socle
inaltérable les valeurs de notre
république la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité la laïcité
mon identité c'est une france plus forte
dans une europe plus indépendante c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
toujours tout le temps c'est le respect
de la laïcité sans accommodements dits
compromission c'est le refus d'opposer
les uns aux autres et de désigner des
boucs émissaires c'est le courage de
dire la vérité aux français
c'est forte de ses convictions des
valeurs que je chéris et protège comme
femme comme citoyenne comme élu comme
premier ministre que je crois
souhaitable et possible que chaque
conviction chaque idée puisse être
défendus débattu et s'il le faut
combattu trop longtemps notre vie
politique n'a été faite que de blogs qui
s'affrontent il est temps d'entrer dans
l'ère des forces qui bâtissent ensemble
une majorité relative n'est pas et ne
sera pas le synonyme d'une action
relative
elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas et ne sera pas de signe
de l'impuissance
rappelons nous qu'en 1958 les gaullistes
les gaullistes ne sont pas majoritaires
à l'assemblée nationale quand la vème
république connaît ses premières armes
et crée les chu et l'assurance chômage
rappelons nous que c'est le gouvernement
rocard qui n'avait pourtant qu'une
majorité relative sur ses bancs qui a
créé le rmi la csg et lancer le
processus de paix en nouvelle calédonie
nous avons encore des droits à conquérir
des progrès à réaliser des protections à
bâtir s'ils y sont parvenus nous y
parviendrons
ces dernières semaines le président de
la république garant de nos actes de nos
institutions et moi même avons consulté
écoutez nous avons proposé plusieurs
manières de faire pour l'urgence comme
pour les années à venir
le résultat de nos échanges est clair
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
politique et parlementaire commence
celle des majorités de projet
avec mon gouvernement
j'en serai l'infatigable bâtisseuse
je sais combien nous sommes attendus et
je ne suis pas femme à me dérober ni
devant les défis ni devant les débats
[Applaudissements]
attendez cela tombe bien la situation
est inédite
je n'ai pas le complexe de la femme
providentielle j'ai été ingénieur femme
d'entreprise préfète ministre mon
parcours on a suivi qu'un fil rouge
servir
je ne suis pas une femme de grandes
phrases et de petits mots je suis
convaincu que ses habitudes ont nourri
les postures la défiance et la crise de
notre démocratie
pour ma part je crois en trois choses
l'écoutent l'action et les résultats je
n'ai qu'une boussole ici
je n'ai qu'une boussole qui sera celle
de mon gouvernement
bâtir pour notre pays
alors mon gouvernement ne sera jamais
celui des clivages factice et des idées
toutes faites car je crois fermement au
dépassement entamé il ya cinq ans par le
président de la république
je suis fier d'avoir servi dans les
gouvernements de premier ministre qui
n'avait pas la même histoire politique
que moi fier de mener aujourd'hui une
équipe diverse ou les parcours et les
expériences se complètent et se
renforcent
pierre est impatiente de commencer avec
vous un travail de fond et d'idées
projet par projet au service des
français
nous mènerons pour chaque sujet une
concertation danse nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
et de compromis et d'ouverture nous
inscrirons dans le cadre et les valeurs
portées par le projet du président de la
république
je les dis au président de groupe de
cette assemblée nous sommes prêts à
entendre les propositions venues de
chacun à en débattre et si nous
partageons les objectifs et les valeurs
à amender notre projet cette méthode de
travail nous devrons l'incarner pour
réfléchir collectivement à l'avenir et
aux évolutions de nos institutions sous
l'égide du président de la république
une commission de transparence izan sera
lancé à la rentrée pour y parvenir
cette méthode nous devrons la porter au
delà des murs de cette assemblée nous
associerons davantage les élus locaux à
nos réflexions et nos décisions ils sont
le ciment de notre république nous
devons laisser des marges de manoeuvre
aux territoires car c'est dans les
solutions différenciées que se trouvent
les résultats qu'on crée la vraie
égalité
je ne crois pas que notre école notre
santé connaissent les mêmes défis dans
le centre de paris dans les quartiers de
cayenne dans un village au bord de la
vire nous consulterons plus encore les
corps intermédiaires des forces vives de
notre pays les françaises et les
français dans chaque territoire
plus que jamais nous mènerons chaque
réforme en lien étroit avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
nous avons besoin d'elles et elles
savent qu'elles trouveront en moi une
interloqué une interlocutrice franches
constructives et déterminé
associer toutes les forces vives du pays
dans un dialogue renouvelé et en
partageant les opportunités comme les
contraintes c'est le sens du conseil
national de la refondation voulue par le
président de la république
[Applaudissements]
les français nous attendent
ils n'accepteront ni immobilisme ni
obstruction ni invectives ils veulent un
gouvernement et un parlement d'action
nous avons une responsabilité historique
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
responsabilité dans la manière d'agir
dans les réponses à offrir dans les
résultats à porter
alors à partir du cadre qu'ont choisi
les français je vous propose de bâtir
ensemble
notre premier défi et je sais que cela
fait consensus parmi nous c'est de
répondre à l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république
de nombreuses mesures ont été prises
depuis l'automne dernier pour protéger
les français de l'augmentation des prix
sans elle les prix de l'électricité
aurait augmenté d'un tiers grâce à elle
la hausse a été limitée à 4% sans elle
les prix du gaz devraient augmenter de
45% grâce à elle les prix ont été
bloqués
sans elle un plein de 60 litres
coûterait 11 euros de plus nous avons
réalisé un investissement rapide et
massif pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français grâce à lui notre inflation est
la plus faible de la zone euro nous
avons protégé les français nous allons
continuer car beaucoup de nos
concitoyens reste à la merci de chaque
hausse de prix dès demain mon
gouvernement présentera en conseil des
ministres des textes d'urgence face à
l'inflation ils comporteront des mesures
concrètes rapides et efficaces nous vous
proposerons de prolonger le bouclier
tarifaires sur les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité
augmenter les revenus du travail et de
mieux partager la valeur en baissant les
charges sur les indépendants et en
triplant le plafond de la prime de
pouvoir d'achat de revaloriser les
retraites et les prestations sociales
notamment les allocations familiales la
prime d'activité les apl l'allocation
adulte handicapé de revaloriser les
bourses sur critères sociaux d'aider les
travailleurs pour lesquels la voiture
est une nécessité
ces mesures sont notre base de travail
avec mon gouvernement nous serons à
votre écoute et nous les amènerons quand
des convergences émergeront
au-delà de l'urgence pour la plupart des
français le logement et la première
dépense nous voulons qu'ils soient
abordables pour chacun nous avons décidé
d'un plafonnement de la hausse des
loyers et nous proposeront de nouvelles
solutions pour que le logement soit
accessible partout en ouvrant la caution
publique aux classes moyennes en
construisant davantage de logements dans
les zones en tension en concluant un
pacte de confiance avec les acteurs du
logement social en proposant aux
collectivités un nouvel acte de
décentralisation pour concentrer les
moyens et les responsabilités à
l'échelle des bassins de vie tout en
étant exigeant pour qu'elle permette au
projet de sortir de terre le pouvoir
d'achat c'est aussi la garantir à tous
l'accès à une alimentation saine et de
qualité nous définirons avec les
professionnels avec les associations
avec vous les contours du chèque
alimentation
le pouvoir d'achat c'est venir en aide
aux plus vulnérables
nous voulons que chacun perçoivent les
aides auxquelles il a droit avec la
solidarité à la source mettront fin à
l'injustice sociale du non recours et
nous lutterons plus efficacement contre
la fraude
mais je veux l'affirmé les deux clés du
pouvoir d'achat durable c'est le plein
emploi c'est la transition écologique
j'y reviendrai sur tous ces sujets je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons trouver
des solutions communes mais nous devrons
garder en tête trois principes la
responsabilité environnementale d'abord
nous devons prendre en compte l'impact
environnemental de toutes nos mesures et
remplacé dès que possible les dépenses
en faveur des énergies fossiles par des
solutions décarbonés la responsabilité
budgétaire ensuite les mesure massives
que nous avons mises en oeuvre ont
protégé les français il fallait les
prendre
mais aujourd'hui nous devons retrouver
des perspectives claires pour
l'amélioration de nos comptes publics
c'est une nécessité pour continuer à
financer notre modèle social c'est un
devoir vis-à-vis des générations futures
une déclaration de politique générale
c'est un moment de vérité un moment de
partage aussi des contraintes des
contraintes auxquelles nous faisons face
les données sont claires du fait de la
guerre qui dure et comme partout en
europe notre croissance économique sera
plus faible que prévu l'inflation sera
plus fort et la charge de la dette
augmente nos objectifs sont eux aussi
clair en 2026 nous devons commencer à
baisser la dette en 2027 nous devrons
ramener le déficit sous les 3%
ces objectifs nous les atteindrons en
bâtissant les conditions d'une
croissance forte et durable qui créera
les emplois en menant les réformes
nécessaires en prenant des mesures de
bonne gestion et en accentuant la lutte
contre les fraudes
équilibre de nos finances publiques est
une question de souveraineté je sais que
beaucoup y sont attachées sur ses bancs
nous en avons parlé justement monsieur
le président marc l'ex
enfin notre troisième principe c'est le
respect ferme de l'engagement pris par
le président de la république devant les
français
c'est le respect de l'engagement pris
par le président de la république devant
les français pas s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues
nous devons cesser de nous devons cesser
de croire qu'à chaque défi la solution
est une taxe alors pas de hausse d'impôt
nous sommes crédibles nous avons
supprimé la dac la taxe d'habitation et
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu au total
nous avons diminué les impôts des
français ont des entreprises de plus de
50 milliards pendant le précédent
quinquennat
de cet été nous tiendrons parole la
suppression de la redevance auto
audiovisuel permettra de faire
économiser 138 euros à plus de 20
millions de foyers
elle ira de pair avec une réforme du
financement de l'audiovisuel public qui
garantira son indépendance et des moyens
pérennes nous y travaillerons ensemble
la fiscalité sera un de nos terrains de
débat mais elle peut aussi être un sujet
de consensus entre nous nous en parlions
monsieur le président mattei
j'ajoute que le pouvoir d'achat est un
combat collectif
chacun doit y prendre sa part et
notamment les entreprises qui dégagent
des marges au moment où l'inflation est
forte j'attends des employeurs qui le
peuvent qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités
nous pouvons nous devons aller plus loin
en la matière
notre deuxième défi c'est de bâtir
ensemble la société du plein emploi
c'est une conviction qui m'anime
profondément une conviction nourri par
mon parcours par deux ans que ministre
du travail par nos échanges et parce que
j'ai avec nos concitoyens
nous devons changer notre rapport au
travail et le coeur de ce changement
c'est le plein emploi et le bon emploi
ce n'est pas une illusion ça n'est pas
un objectif inatteignable
aujourd'hui le plein emploi est à notre
portée et le travail reste pour moi un
levier majeur d'émancipation
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
déjà parcouru la moitié du chemin vers
le plein emploi nous avons le taux de
chômage le plus bas depuis 15 ans le
taux de chômage des jeunes le plus bas
depuis 40 ans la part des français qui
ont un travail qui n'a jamais été aussi
élevées depuis quand la mesure
c'est le résultat des réformes de fond
que nous avons menée pendant cinq ans
nous avons déverrouiller l'apprentissage
avec plus de 700000 apprentis en 2021
nous avons rendu le travail toujours
plus incitatif avec la réforme de
l'assurance chômage nous avons amélioré
et intensifier la formation des
demandeurs d'emplois en investissant 15
milliards d'euros dans la formation
professionnelle
nous avons mieux accompagner les jeunes
grâce au plan un jeune une solution et
aux contrats d'engagement jeunes
c'est grâce à ce bilan que nous pouvons
désormais viser le plein emploi j'ai la
conviction profonde que notre pays doit
et peut sortir du cercle vicieux du
chômage de masse
aujourd'hui la situation de l'emploi a
changé dans notre pays de nombreuses
entreprises dans toutes les filières
dans tous les métiers et dans tous les
territoires cherche à recruter cette
situation a des vertus elle impose aux
employeurs d'améliorer les conditions de
travail de questionner leur mode de
management et devrait à l'attractivité
de leur métier avec le plein emploi les
travailleurs retrouvent le pouvoir de
négocier et pour atteindre le plein
emploi nous devrons aussi ramener vers
l'emploi celles et ceux qui sont le plus
éloignés du marché du travail je pense
aux jeunes bien sûr que nous
continuerons à accompagner mais je pense
aussi aux bénéficiaires du rsa ce que
nous voulons c'est leur permettre de
retrouver un travail
comme le disait michel rocard ne perdons
pas la volonté tenace de l'insertion
revenons à l'esprit du rmi et du rsa
verser une allocation ne suffit pas
c'est que nous voulons c'est que chacun
s'en sortent et retrouve sa dignité par
le travail
ce que nous proposons c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une mesure de justice sociale
et d'équilibré entre les droits et des
devoirs
[Applaudissements]
le plein emploi nous l'atteindrons aussi
en accompagnant mieux les chômeurs
aujourd'hui notre organisation est trop
complexe son efficacité en pâtit nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à avoir d'un côté
l'état qui accompagne les demandeurs
d'emploi de l'autre les régions qui
s'occupent de leur formation et les
départements en charge de l'insertion
des bénéficiaires du rsa
c'est pour cela que nous voulons
transformer pôle emploi en france
travaillent
[Applaudissements]
nous devons joindre nos forces
travailler ensemble pour être plus
efficace dans l'accompagnement des
chômeurs c'est comme ça que chaque
français trouvera sa place dans le
marché du travail et que nous répondrons
aux besoins de recrutement des
entreprises
le plein emploi c'est aussi relever le
défi de la découverte des métiers de
l'orientation et de la formation
cela commence dès l'enseignement
secondaire
avec les régions nous ferons en sorte
que chaque élève puisse découvrir et
connaître des métiers notamment ceux de
l'artisanat de l'industrie du tourisme
les métiers d'art nous élargirons au
lycée professionnel le succès de
l'apprentissage mais ce défi ne s'arrête
pas à la fin du lycée nous devrons dans
le supérieur permettent que les
étudiants choisissent et se lance dans
une voie en fonction du métier qu'ils
veulent exercer
mais grâce à la formation tout au long
de la vie qu'ils puissent se sentir
libres d'en changer et de saisir de
nouvelles opportunités
grâce à cela ces prochaines années nous
pourrons former un million de jeunes
dans les métiers d'avenir dont la moitié
dans le numérique
enfin c'est grâce au plein emploi que
nous créerons de la richesse et que nous
pourrons financer notre modèle social
vous le savez nous avons toujours dit
les choses clairement aux françaises et
aux français
en la matière
en la matière la transparence est une
exigence les faux semblants un manque de
respect pour nos concitoyens
notre modèle social est un paradoxe à la
fois l'un des plus généreux est l'un de
ceux où l'on travaille de moins
longtemps notre système de retraite est
une exception alors que l'on part plus
tard j'ai la totalité de nos voisins
européens
alors je le dis aujourd'hui pour la
prospérité de notre pays et la pérennité
de notre système par répartition pour
bâtir de nouveaux progrès sociaux pour
coca retraités avec une carrière
complète mais une pension inférieure à
1100 euros par mois pour sortir de
situations où le même métier ne garantit
pas la même retraite oui nous devrons
travailler progressivement un peu plus
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
notre pays a besoin d'une réforme de son
système de retraites elle ne sera pas
uniforme et devra prendre en compte les
carrières longues et la pénibilité
elle devra veiller au maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors
mon gouvernement
la mènera dans la concertation avec les
parents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
laisser madame la première ministre
continuer
vos gouvernements l'amènera dans la
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
en associant les parlementaires le plus
en amont possible
elle n'est pas ficelé elle ne sera pas à
prendre ou à laisser mais elle est
indispensable
j'ajoute que je ne peux pas que nous ne
pouvons pas nous résoudre à la
pénibilité de certains métiers par
l'innovation par la technologie par
l'évolution des carrières nous pouvons
nous devons améliorer les conditions de
travail et faire en sorte que nos
compatriotes ne finissent plus leur
carrière brisée
alors oui le travail est une valeur
essentielle le travail c'est la clef de
l'émancipation c'est la création de
richesse la liberté d'entreprendre le
partage de la valeur des ressources
complémentaires pour notre modèle social
une ambition plus fort dans la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises nous
avons tous à y gagner
mesdames et messieurs les députés bâtir
ensemble c'est apporter des réponses
radicales à l'urgence écologique
devant les défis il n'est plus question
d'opposer les radicaux aux partisans
d'une écologie des petits par tous nous
avons conscience des enjeux et des
risques tous nous devons faire bloc ce
mot de radicalité je le prends donc à
mon compte nous engagerons des
transformations radicales dans notre
manière de produire de nous loger de
nous déplacer de consommer mais je la
firme je ne crois pas un instant que
cette révolution climatique passe par la
décroissance au contraire
au contraire la révolution écologique
que nous voulons mener ce sont des
innovations des filières nouvelles des
emplois d'avenir c'est un modèle social
préserver car sans activité nous ne
pourrions plus le financer au cours des
cinq dernières années nous avons
accéléré la baisse des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais nous devons faire
plus sous l'impulsion de la france
l'europe s'est fixée l'objectif d'être
neutre en carbone en 2050 et de réduire
ses émissions de 55 % d'ici 2030 ces
objectifs nous devons les atteindre
ensemble nous gagnerons la bataille du
climat
[Applaudissements]
pour y parvenir tout mon gouvernement
est mobilisé le président de la
république m'a chargé de la
planification écologique
chaque ministre aura une feuille de
route climats et biodiversité
nous allons définir ensemble un plan
d'action un plan de bataille dès le mois
de septembre
nous lancerons une vaste concertation en
vue d'une loi d'orientation énergie
climat
filière par filière territoire par
territoire nous définirons des objectifs
de réduction d'émissions des étapes et
des moyens appropriés la transition
écologique et la sphère de tous les
dirigeants des grandes entreprises
doivent montrer l'exemple et leur
rémunération dépendra de l'atteinte des
objectifs environnementaux
nous avancerons avec les élus locaux ils
ont en charge l'aménagement du
territoire les transports l'habitat les
déchets nous avons besoin d'eux et c'est
le sens même de la création d'un
ministère de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires ils
seront également source d'inspiration
d'initiative et 10 des biens sont bien
souvent dans leur territoire ils ont
montré le chemin
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
voulons être nous serons la première
grande nation écologique à sortir des
énergies fossiles
c'est la garantie de notre souveraineté
énergétique c'est la préservation du
pouvoir d'achat ce sont des filières
industrielles nouvelles et des emplois
créés et quand je le dis et je le répète
notre écologie est une écologie de
progrès je laissais cette transition
peut parfois provoquer des craintes
notamment des salariés des secteurs en
mutation
madame la présidente châtelain monsieur
le président bayou nous en avons parlé
et nous y tenons comme vous
voulez
nous ne laisserons personne sur le bord
de la route nous avons retenu les leçons
du textile et de l'acier chaque
transition ira de pair avec un
accompagnement pour la formation et la
reconversion
pour sortir du carbone nous noterons
d'un mix énergétique équilibré autour
des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire nous accélérons le déploiement
des énergies renouvelables nous
investirons dans le nucléaire avec la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs et
des innovations seront par m culture
la transition énergétique passe par le
nucléaire je sais que c'est une
conviction largement partagé sur ses
bancs
c'est une énergie décarbonée souveraine
et compétitive
réussir la transition énergétique
c'est pouvoir la piloter
je le disais
je le disais il ya quelques instants
l'urgence climatique impose des
décisions fortes radical nous devons
avoir la pleine maîtrise de notre
production d'électricité et de sa
performance nous devons assurer notre
souveraineté face aux conséquences de la
guerre et aux défis colossaux à venir
nous devons prendre des décisions que
sur ses bancs même d'autres ont pu
prendre avant nous dans une période de
l'histoire ou le pays devait aussi gagné
la bataille de l'énergie et de la
production c'est pourquoi je vous
confirme aujourd'hui l'intention de
l'état de détenir 100% du capital d'edf
[Applaudissements]
cette évolution permettra à edf de
renforcer sa capacité à mener dans les
meilleurs délais des projets ambitieux
est indispensable pour notre avenir
énergétique
[Applaudissements]
réussir la transition énergétique s'est
ensuite consommer moins si notre pays
est moins dépendants du gaz russe que
nos voisins nous ne pouvons pas croire
ou faire croire que les décisions
unilatérales de la russie nous
épargnerait si la rue s'ils venaient à
couper ses exportations de gaz nous
serions tous chez nous aussi
dès maintenant nous devons envisager
tous les scénarios concrets même les
plus difficiles et partager leurs
conséquences avec tous les acteurs et
avec les français nous pouvons tenir
mais chacun devra agir
plus largement
nous devons éviter toutes les
consommations inutiles dans le domaine
du logement nous amplifierons le succès
de ma prime rénove pour rénover 700
mille logements par an
nous voulons permettre à chacun d'avoir
accès à des transports propres cela vaut
partout en ville partout pardon en ville
comme dans la ruralité
le ferroviaire est et restera la colonne
vertébrale d'une mobilité propre
nous continuerons les investissements de
ces dernières années pour les transports
du quotidien pour les petites lignes je
veux ici rendre hommage
à l'action de jean castex
l'infatigable voix
voir
et qui s'est engagé personnellement pour
le ferroviaire
partout des solutions alternatives à
usage individuel de la voiture thermique
devront être construites par tous nous
devons continuer à soutenir les
mobilités propre et active
nous souhaitons permettre aux français
d'avoir accès à une voiture zéro
émission
pour y parvenir nous prolongerons les
aides à la conversion et nous mettrons
en place un système de location de
longue durée à moins de 100 euros par
mois
c'est un projet écologique
c'est une ambition industrielle car nous
construirons ces voitures électriques en
france
au delà des transports partout nous
allons décarbonée c'est vrai notamment
dans l'industrie en nous appuyant sur
les 50 milliards d'investissements de
france 2030 la moitié au moins sera
consacrée à ces enjeux cela vaut aussi
pour l'agriculture en continuant à
transformer notre modèle agricole j'y
reviendrai
protéger l'environnement s'est enfin
préserver la nature et la biodiversité
face au risque d'une sixième grande
extinction nous accentuerons notre
politique de préservation des espaces
naturels
forêts montagnes littoraux océans nous
aurons une attention toute particulière
pour nous outre-mer dont la biodiversité
est un trésor inestimable
nous devrons enfin poursuivre notre
sortie de la société du gaspillage et du
tout jetable
il faut du réemploi de la réparation du
recyclage cela crée de l'activité du
pouvoir d'achat les outils ont été mis
en place lors du précédent quinquennat
il faut maintenant pleinement s'en
emparer
vous le voyez derrière les mots derrière
les engagements d'urgence nous impose
des actes rapides tout ne viendra pas de
l'état seul chacun devra y prendre sa
part c'est la condition de la réussite
mesdames et messieurs au cours de nos
échanges
j'ai vu de se dégager une autre volonté
commune bâtir la république de l'égalité
des chances
nous refusons une société où la vie et
les destins sont rasées selon le
quartier où l'on naît selon le lieu où
l'on vit selon la couleur de sa peau ou
la profession de ses parents
alors au coeur de l'engagement du
président de la république et de mon
gouvernement se trouve une volonté de
briser les inégalités de destins
n'accepter aucune assignation sociale ou
culture culture elle de permettre à
chacun de choisir son avenir de tracer
les chemins de l'émancipation
la république de l'égalité des chances
se construit dès la naissance
l'enfance sera une priorité de ce
quinquennat dans la droite ligne du
chantier des 1000 premiers jours nous
répondrons à la première préoccupation
des parents aujourd'hui le manque de
solutions de garde pour les enfants et
notamment les enfants de moins de 3 ans
pour réussir mon gouvernement souhaite
bâtir avec les collectivités un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance il permettra d'offrir les deux
cent mille places d'accueil manquantes
nous voulons des solutions proche des
domiciles accessible financièrement nous
viendront en aide en priorité à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin les parents qui
élèvent seules leurs enfants le plus
souvent des femmes pour eux pour elle
nous continuerons à bâtir un
accompagnement global avec les pensions
alimentaires désormais directement
versés sur les comptes en banque nous
avons franchi une étape majeure
nous continuerons et nous accorderons
une aide aux familles monoparentales
pour la garde des enfants jusqu'à 12 ans
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir en priorité pour
l'école et la jeunesse c'est un chantier
essentiel c'est là que tout se joue nous
continuerons la refondation de l'école
en gamme entamée lors du dernier
quinquennat
notre école c'est celle qui conforte les
savoirs fondamentaux
savoirs fondamentaux lire écrire compter
respecter autrui et s'empare des
nouveaux savoirs comme le codage
informatique
notre école c'est celle qui garantit
l'égalité et ne renonce jamais à
l'excellence nous devons pousser chaque
élève à se dépasser dans notre école
nous devons aider les jeunes à déceler
et faire éclore ces talents les adultes
à déceler même s'ils ne sont pas même
s'ils ne sont pas dans le moule former
des millions de jeunes et s'adapter aux
personnalités de chacun c'est le défi
auquel font face chaque jour les
professeurs et notre école se doit donc
donc être celle qui offre aux
enseignants la reconnaissance et la
place qu'il mérite
nous enseignons sont le coeur battant de
la république et grâce à leur
mobilisation durant la crise sanitaire
ils ont permis à notre école de rester
ouverte nous devons mieux les associer à
la transformation de l'école nour
valoriseront leur salaire et
construiront avec les évolutions de leur
profession
avec nous devrons bâtir un nouveau pacte
répondre à la question des remplacements
avancé pour l'aide individualisée
adapter leur formation soutenir les
projets collectifs
mais il serait illusoire de croire que
les solutions seraient identiques
partout sur tous les territoires
l'égalité réelle s'est adapté notre
action en fonction des situations
locales et des besoins des élèves le
plan marseillan grand lancés par le
président de la république l'année
dernière a ouvert la voie
[Applaudissements]
nous donneront des marges de manoeuvre
aux établissements pour s'adapter nous
mobiliserons toute la communauté
scolaire les associations les élus car
l'émancipation de nos jeunes passe par
l'école mais aussi par le sport la
culture l'engagement l'égalité réelle
nous la construirons dans le dialogue
avec toutes les parties prenantes cette
concertation sera lancée dès septembre
notre jeunesse doit également continuer
à faire vivre les valeurs républicaines
mon gouvernement continuera à déployer
le service national universel
l'avenir de notre jeunesse enfin passe
par un enseignement supérieur et une
recherche avec les moyens de ses
ambitions
l'université française est une chance
précieuse elle forme et aiguise les
esprits elle assure la transmission et
le progrès des savoirs dans tous les
champs de connaissance
l'université sera donc au coeur de
l'action de notre gouvernement nous
améliorons les conditions de vie et
d'études de nos jeunes et new rave
renforceront l'égalité d'accès et de
réussite en particulier dans le premier
cycle universitaire et simplifieront le
système de bourses étudiantes
l'avenir de notre jeunesse s'est aussi
accompagné toutes les voix de
l'émancipation
assumant d'être une grande nation
culturelle la culture sauf la culture
grandi la culture fait l'âme et le
rayonnement de notre pays rendons la
culture accessible à toutes et tous et
la jeunesse
c'est pourquoi nous proposerons
d'étendre le bass culture dès la 6è et
d'amplifier l'éducation artistique et
culturelle
soutenons la création dans l'espace
physique comme numérique prolongeons
notre action pour sauvegarder le
patrimoine c'est notre identité notre
héritage notre histoire
bâtissons une nation sportive le sport
donne sa chance à tous offrons à chaque
élève en primaire 30 minutes de sport
par jour faisons des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 un accélérateur de
l'activité physique dans notre pays
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est offrir à toutes et tous
une santé de qualité
les français le savent ils nous le
disent nous faisons face à un manque
criant de personnel de professionnels de
santé 7
cette réalité nous ne pouvons ni la nier
ni le culte et si nous avons supprimé le
numerus clausus en 2018
nous devons aussi dire les choses cette
situation durera encore plusieurs années
face à ce défi nous devons activer tous
les leviers le premier c'est la
prévention trop souvent à tort on résume
la santé aux soins la prévention ce sont
des campagnes de santé publique les
dépistages et et les bilans de santé ou
moments clés de la vie mais bien au delà
ce doit être une vision de toutes les
politiques publiques prévenir les
maladies c'est agir sur la qualité de
l'air sur l'habitat sur les conditions
de vie c'est prendre en compte les
inégalités sociales qui sont aujourd'hui
les principaux déterminants de la santé
de chacun
c'est pourquoi avec le président de la
république nous avons souhaité que le
gouvernement comprenne un ministre de la
santé et de la prévention c'est un défi
que l'état ne peut pas relever seul nous
travaillerons avec les élus et en
particulier les maires qui sont nos
partenaires privilégiés
ensuite nous devrons soutenir les
soignants le coc vide a mis à jour les
fragilités de notre système de soins
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
il a aussi montré l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et je veux
leur rendre hommage
[Applaudissements]
les chars collègues s'il vous plaît
pas de telles manifestations dans
l'hémicycle s'il vous plaît madame la
première miss continue
ça n'a rien
à
c'est d'abord grâce à nos soignants que
notre pays a tenu notre de vin et de
continuer à agir
ne ségur de la santé a permis des
revalorisations sans précédent des
rémunérations des soignants ont des
moyens inédits pour notre hôpital
pourtant tout n'est pas réglé loin de là
nous avons pris des mesures d'urgence
pour cet été l'heure est maintenant aux
solutions structurantes nous devons
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
nous devons permettre aux soignants de
passer plus de temps auprès des patients
en allégeant la charge administrative et
en renforçant la coopération entre les
professionnels de santé nous devons
investir sur l'innovation pour
moderniser notre système de soin nous
devons construire dans chaque territoire
une offre de santé adaptés je suis
convaincu que les solutions viendront
des professionnels des élus des patients
et du terrain
dès septembre des concertations se
relançait partout en france avec un
objectif clair lutter contre les déserts
médicaux par une meilleure coordination
entre les acteurs entre la ville et
l'hôpital entre le public et le privé
nombreux
pas mon parent
sur ce sujet si nous pouvons construire
des consensus
[Applaudissements]
je vais ici aussi rappelé que l'épidémie
de covin n'est pas finie et qu'elle
reprend même nettement ces derniers
jours si notre système de santé est
aujourd'hui préservée nous devons rester
vigilants et prêts à agir
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est faire de la france un pays
où l'on vieillit bien un pays qui
favorise l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé un pays qui assure une prise en
charge de qualité à domicile ou en
maison de retraite notre première
mission donnée aux personnes âgées la
capacité de vieillir sereinement chez
zen nous y parviendrons avec le
dispositif bas prix m'adapte pour leur
permettre d'aménager leur logement
nous y parviendrons en améliorant la
qualité des services à domicile mais il
nous faut aussi améliorer la vie de nos
aînés en maison de retraite des
scandales récents sont révoltants nous
avons renforcé les contrôles pour qu'il
ne puisse plus survenir nous devons
maintenant inventer les établissements
de demain à la fois plus ouvert plus
humain et mieux médicalisé nous devons
construire des liens plus forts entre
établissements et domicile créé des
ehpad hors les murs pour une prise en
charge toujours plus adaptée à chaque
situation
les investissements du ségur ont été une
étape majeure pour cette transformation
mais nous devons aussi relevé le défi de
l'attractivité pour permettre le
recrutement de 50 mille infirmiers et
aides soignants d'ici 2027
lors du précédent quinquennat nous avons
créé la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale
nous avons posé
comment du financement de cette nouvelle
solidarité nationale pour le grand âge
là encore avec les départements je vous
propose de travailler ensemble et de
bâtir un service public efficace qui
répondent aux besoins des personnes
âgées et des familles au plus près des
territoires
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est aussi construire une
société inclusive
le handicap ces 12 millions de français
c'est un conjoint un parent un enfant
toutes nos familles sont conservées au
fond leur une société qui accepte qui
inclut qui respecte
une conférence nationale du handicap se
tiendra début 2023 nous agirons pour
l'accessibilité universelle
pour l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées notamment financières pas
pour la transformation des structures
médico sociales pour une rom meilleure
reconnaissance des personnels de
l'accompagnement nous devons améliorer
l'inclusion par le travail dans le
milieu ordinaire d'abord ainsi que dans
les esat ou en entreprise adaptée et je
vous annonce que mon gouvernement
réformera avec vous avec les
associations l'allocation adulte
handicapé
[Applaudissements]
il s'agira d'une réforme en profondeur
nous partirons du principe de la dea
conjugale isation
c'est une question
c'est une question de dignité et une
avancée très attendu à
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est réussir la cohésion des
territoires avec les territoires avec
leurs élus nous voulons une relation
fondée sur le respect le dialogue et
l'action c'est une préoccupation
partagée nous avons nous en avons
beaucoup parlé ensemble monsieur le
président marc angeli le sureau
président chassaigne je veux saluer
l'engagement et la détermination des
élus locaux je les dis les politiques
publiques doivent se construire avec eux
la crise sanitaire la montre et quand
nous travaillons main dans la main nous
pouvons tout surmonté les cinq dernières
années ont permis de commencer à réduire
les factures de notre france nous avons
créé plus de 2000 maisons fan-service
nous avons investi pour redynamiser les
centres villes et les centres bourgs et
accélérer le renouvellement urbain mon
gouvernement poursuivra la logique de
différenciation partout elle répond aux
attentes monsieur le président
penchèrent nous n'avons évoqué ensemble
la
règle commune doit pouvoir s'adapter en
fonction des spécificités de chaque
territoire nous voulons donner plus de
poids aux élus locaux plus de visibilité
dans leurs compétences plus de cohérence
dans leurs actions le conseiller
territorial
peut-être un moyen d'y parvenir est de
construire les complémentarités
indispensable entre départements et
régions
cela passera naturellement par des
concertations approfondies que nous
lancerons l'an prochain pour mener à
bien leur mission les collectivités ont
besoin de visibilité et de stabilité
dans leurs compétences c'est l'enjeu de
l'agenda territoriale que nous devons
bâtir ensemble état et collectivités
doit se donner une lecture commune des
défis à relever des leviers à activer
des moyens nécessaires en corse le cycle
des discussions engagées
les élus et les forces vives sera
relancé dans les prochains jours il doit
aboutir à des solutions concrètes pour
tous les corses et notamment la jeunesse
des solutions concrètes pour le travail
pour le logement pour la transition
écologique pour le développement
économique et la sécurité
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir tous les
sujets y compris institutionnels allait
discuter en transparence dans un esprit
constructif et responsable
il ne cédons pas à la facilité répondons
au cas par cas à ceux qui bloquent ou
dysfonctionne
mon gouvernement sera aussi celui de la
justice territoriale quartiers
prioritaires ou ruraux nos territoires
partage des défis communs bâti dégradé
manque de transports collectifs accès à
la santé et à l'emploi sécurité de tous
les territoires de france j'entends
cette demande commune de justice de
cohésion de considération nous allons y
répondre pour nos quartiers nous
bâtirons des solutions qui change le
quotidien et redonne des opportunités
nous définirons les nouveaux contrats de
ville et répondront aux urgences avec
les habitants avec les associations avec
les élus locaux
ils mèneront des opérations de
renouvellement urbain est essentielle
car l'égalité cela commence par l'état
de sa rue de son hall d'immeuble et de
son école pour la ruralité nous
continuerons à investir un nouvel agenda
rural sera mis en oeuvre nous
continuerons le déploiement de france
service pour garantir des services
publics de proximité et de qualité aux
habitants
nous lutterons contre la fracture
numérique
nous irons au bout de la couverture
mobile et très haut débit de notre
territoire nous accélérons les formation
et l'accompagnement aux usages
numériques
la cohésion des territoires ce sont
aussi des fonctionnaires présents
partout et un état qui répond vite et
bien aux demandes des français c'est
donner au fonctionnaire les moyens de
leur action nous continuerons la
modernisation de l'état c'est offrir aux
agents des trois versants de la fonction
publique une reconnaissance et de
meilleures conditions de travail
c'est le sens notamment de la
revalorisation du point d'indicé la plus
importante depuis près de 40 ans
je vais aussi avoir un mot particulier
pour nos compatriotes d outre mer les
outre mer sont une chance inestimable
pour notre pays ce sont des terres de
jeunesse et d'espoir ce sont les places
fortes de notre souveraineté plus que
jamais nous avons besoin de nos outre
mer
pourtant ces derniers mois vous avez dit
vos doutes vos craintes et vos colères
il y a quelques jours toutes les
collectivités d'outre-mer se sont
rassemblés pour lancer l'appel de fort
de france nous leur répondrons mon
gouvernement les accompagnera pour
soutenir leur développement économique
et créer de l'emploi pour renforcer la
présence des services publics et assurer
la sécurité pour améliorer avec les
collectivités la distribution d'eau
potable l'assainissement le traitement
des déchets pour agir sur toutes les
causes de la vie chère comme dans
l'hexagone nous devons avancer sur tous
ces sujets
placez les outre-mer aux avant postes de
la transition écologique et je demande à
tous mon gouvernement
la plus grande attention pour les
territoires ultramarins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce quinquennat serait également celui
d'une nouvelle page de notre histoire
républicaine avec la nouvelle calédonie
nous aurons à écrire l'avenir de notre
relation au terme du processus politique
définie par l'accord de nouméa de nouméa
les discussions seront engagées avec
l'ensemble des parties j'y prendrai
comme mes prédécesseurs tout ma part et
je veux ici rendre hommage à l'action
d'edouard philippe figure du sens donné
à face aux crises
chacun connaît son engagement pour
l'avenir la nouvelle calédonie
bâtir la république de l'égalité des
chances c'est agir pour notre sécurité
c'est une conviction qui m'anime
profondément une conviction qui
s'échangeaient tout au long de mon
parcours en particulier sous l'uniforme
de prêt fait car la sécurité c'est une
inégalité
l'insécurité touche directement in
violemment ce qu'ils ont déjà été
fragilisés par la vie ce qui dit dans
des quartiers où des zones où certains
cherchent à imposer leur loi face à
celle de la république le combat pour la
sécurité c'est donc un combat pour
l'égalité ce combat mon gouvernement ne
mènera avec fermeté j'ai confiance dans
nos forces de l'ordre et j'ai le plus
grand respect pour elle c'est pour cela
que j'ai envers elle la plus grande
exigence
mais je le dis sans détour
honte à ceux qui attaquent
systématiquement nos policiers et nos
gendarmes ont passé une qui tente de
dresser des procès contre ceux qui les
protègent
nous voulons une gendarmerie et une
police républicaine au plus près des
français les français veulent des
réponses fortes pour leur sécurité du
quotidien nous en parlions ensemble mme
haddad la présidente berger les cinq
dernières années ont permis de donner
des moyens exceptionnels à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure nous avons recruté
dix mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires nous avons fortifier
notre sécurité civile et agit pour nos
sapeurs pompiers nous avons renforcé
notre lutte contre le terrorisme et les
moyens de notre nos services de
renseignement en prolongeant l'effort
entamé depuis les attentats de 2015 le
quinquennat qui s'ouvre doit nous
permettre d'amplifier cet effort autour
d'une vision globale et de moyens pour
notre sécurité
c'est pourquoi mon gouvernement vous
proposera une loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur les défis sont nombreux
contre l'insécurité du quotidien contre
la cyber délinquance contre les trafics
nous renforcerons encore les moyens de
notre sécurité je suis élue d'une
circonscription rurale j'étais prêt fait
d'une région largement rurale je sais ce
qu'est le sentiment d'abandon de
certains territoires et la crainte de
voir la sécurité s'éloigner il ne doit
pas y avoir de zone blanche de la
sécurité aussi nous engageons la
création de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie ces dernières années ont
montré la nécessité de mieux assurer
l'ordre républicain nous créerons 11
nouvelles unités de forces mobiles mais
chacun le sait sur ses bancs et les
français nous le disent les solutions ne
se trouve pas uniquement dans des
effectifs supplémentaires
moi j'entends la colère des français
l'exaspération des forces de l'ordre
face aux multirécidivistes
la réponse c'est le refus de l'impunité
nous doublerons le temps de présence des
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain d'ici
[Applaudissements]
cela se fera grâce à leur recrue tu mens
en allégeant les procédures en les
modernisant une profonde réforme de
l'investigation sera mis en place avec
une formation plus longue le passage
obligatoire de l'examen d'officier de
police judiciaire et la création des
assistants d' enquête la réponse c'est
aussi l'efficacité de la justice ce sont
des décisions rapides et respecter les
états généraux de la justice lancée par
le président de la république on
montrait qu'il fallait des moyens
supplémentaires et des méthodes
nouvelles qu'il fallait répondre à la
crise de confiance de nos concitoyens
aux attentes fortes des professionnels
et garantir toujours l'indépendance de
la justice mon gouvernement vous
proposera une loi de programmation pour
la justice nous voulons notamment
recruté 8500 magistrats et personnels de
justice supplémentaire pour une justice
plus proche pour réduire les délais et
permettre aux juges de se concentrer sur
leurs missions fondamentales nous
agirons pour que chaque aide chaque
peine prononcée soit exécuté et pour
lutter contre la surpopulation carcérale
une quarantaine d'établissements
pénitentiaires 15000 places seront
livrés dans les prochaines années je
veux que nous ayons en lien étroit avec
les élus les associations les magistrats
et les forces de l'ordre une action
toujours plus résolu dans la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles sexistes
et les violences intrafamiliales
c'est mon combat je les portais comme
préfète je le porterai comme première
ministre
pour que les victimes soient être
écoutés protéger accompagner pour que
les plaintes soient déposées et la
justice dit c'est une exigence absolue
qui nécessite une mobilisation absolue
enfin bâtir la république de l'égalité
des chances c'est porter nos valeurs et
les défendre avec intransigeance la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité et la
laïcité ne sont pas négociables
la laïcité c'est un pilier de notre
pacte républicain
face à elle le séparatisme et
l'islamisme sont des périls mortels ils
s'en prennent à notre unité républicaine
ils sont le terreau de la radicalisation
et du terrorisme
mon gouvernement continuera à les
combattre de toutes ses forces
l'égalité c'est refuser les
discriminations avec tout mon
gouvernement je serai une combattante
pour l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes elle est la grande cause du
quinquennat
nous agirons dans tous les domaines
notamment pour l'égalité économique
nous lutterons avec intransigeance
contre toutes les discriminations
qu'elles concernent le genre la religion
la couleur de la peau le handicap
l'orientation sexuelle chaque
discrimination est une humiliation une
blessure une violence alors en
concertation avec tous les acteurs nous
continuerons à les prévenir et les
sanctionner
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
voudrais à présent vous parler de notre
souveraineté la souveraineté ça n'est ni
le repli sur soi ni l'exclusion au
contraire c'est notre capacité à peser
et affronter les crises cette
souveraineté est à la fois profondément
française est profondément européenne la
pendule nous a prouvé notre trop forte
dépendance aux industries étrangères la
guerre en ukraine nous a rappelé que
nous devions faire front pour faire
entendre notre voix les crises
migratoires nous ont montré le besoin de
solidarité européenne et la nécessité de
toujours mieux protéger nos frontières
l'union européenne nous protège et nous
projette dans l'avenir une europe plus
fort c'est une france plus fort
la présidence française du conseil
européen a permis plus de 130 accord et
autant de réponses pour le climat le
numérique l'autonomie stratégique les
droits sociaux ou l'égalité des femmes
les défis de la souveraineté nous
attendent bâtissons ensemble une france
plus forte dans une europe plus
indépendante
une france plus forte dans une europe
indépendante c'est la souveraineté
énergétique
nous ne pouvons plus dépendre du gaz et
du pétrole russes je l'évoquais plus tôt
nous gagnerons notre souveraineté
grâce au nucléaire et aux énergies
renouvelables
une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique nous sommes
sur la bonne voie par les baisses
d'impôts par la réforme du marché du
travail par l'attractivité retrouvée
nous avons mis un coup d'arrêt à 40 ans
de désindustrialisation
maintenant accélérons accélérons en
continuant à tirer les entreprises et
les industries
comme annoncé par le président de la
république nous vous proposerons de
baisser encore les impôts de production
et de supprimer la cvae et la loi de
finances 2023
concrètement ce sont près de 8 milliards
qui permettront de renforcer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises aux
trois quarts des pme et des deux pays
concrètement aussi nous compenserons
cette perte de ressources auprès des
collectivités
accélérons en investissant massivement
sur les secteurs d'avenir comme
l'alimentation l'énergie nous spatiale
lait bio médicaments ou l'électronique
bâtissons les filières d'excellence
française et européenne c'est le sens
des 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissements de france 2030 pour
l'innovation pour la recherche on la
réindustrialisation
plus largement nous réinvestissons
investiront dans nos sites
universitaires et nos organismes de
recherche nous continuerons à
revaloriser et à simplifier le métier de
chercheur la recherche quel qu'en soit
le domaine inspire et fait la force de
notre pays je veux rendre hommage à
l'excellence de nos universités et
laboratoires et en disant ces mots je
veux féliciter au nom du gouvernement le
mathématicien hugo duminil copains dans
la médaille qui fait la fierté de toute
notre recherche
accélérons en protégeant et promouvant
notre culture et notre création
accélérons aussi en tenant notre rang de
grandes nations numériques une nation
qui soutient sa french tech inc nation
capable d'apprendre à ces jeunes les
bons usages
capable à travers la régulation de
lutter contre le cyber-harcèlement et la
haine en ligne
une france plus forte dans une europe
plus indépendante c'est notre
souveraineté alimentaire le constat est
édifiant près de la moitié des
agriculteurs prendront leur retraite
d'ici 2030 nous devons assurer l'avenir
de la filière agricole la représentation
nationale a montré au tour de la
question des retraites agricoles
qu'elles pouvaient s'unir pour nos
agriculteurs alors bâtissons ensemble
une loi d'orientation et d'avenir pour
l'agriculture
elle permettra de faire émerger une
nouvelle génération d'agriculteurs
cela passe d'abord par une meilleure
rémunération par le soutien à la
transmission de nos exploitations à
l'entrepreneuriat c'est la poursuite de
notre soutien massif à l'adaptation de
l'agriculture au changement climatique
avec l'assurance récolte avec des moyens
de protection des exploitations c'est
l'investissement pour de nouvelles
productions les protéines végétales
notamment c'est la protection dans les
accords internationaux contre la
concurrence déloyale des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos critères sociaux et
environnementaux
c'est une politique d'alimentation qui
respecte chacun des acteurs et leur
donne une juste rémunération
beaucoup a été fait lors du premier
quinquennat
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez été fait lors du précédent
quinquennat nous devons continuer
mesdames et messieurs les députés une
france plus forte dans une europe plus
indépendante c'est également tenir nos
frontières au niveau européen nous
poursuivrons le travail entamé sous
présidence française pour renforcer
schengen pour des contrôles accrus aux
frontières de l'europe pour une
politique d'asile mieux coordonner au
niveau national la france restera fidèle
à sa tradition d'asile et pour que cette
politique soit juste nous devrons
poursuivre l'accélération du traitement
des demandes à ce que nous accueillons
nous devons offrir une meilleure
intégration par le travail et nous
devons dans le même temps reconduire
plus rapidement ce dont la demande
d'asile a été refusée pour y parvenir
nous allons simplifier et moderniser les
procédures je veux le dire aussi
disposer d'un titre de séjour en france
impose de respecter ses lois nous serons
intransigeants sur ce point
en matière d'immigration irrégulière
nous continuerons notre but à tous les
niveaux nous créerons une force aux
frontières nous poursuivrons notre
combat contre les passeurs ils auraient
ils organisent des véritables trafic
d'êtres humains doivent être poursuivis
et sanctionnés une france plus forte
dans une europe plus indépendante enfin
c'est notre souveraineté stratégique la
guerre aux portes de l'europe et le
maintien de la menace terroriste
nous le rappelle nous devons pouvoir
nous défendre nous devons pouvoir faire
entendre notre voix au levant au sahel
sur le flanc est de l'europe sur terre
dans les airs sur les mers dans le
cyberespace
partout et dans tous les milieux nous
armer se bat pour notre liberté parfois
au péril de leur vie je veux dire à nous
armer de plein sud à la confiance du
gouvernement de la nation ici représente
une je veux leur rendre hommage et avoir
une pensée pour nos soldats tombés au
combat pour les familles endeuillées et
pour tous ceux revenus des terrains
d'opération meurtris dans leur chair
tout dans leur esprit
le contexte géopolitique et les
désordres du monde nous oblige nous
devons disposer d'un modèle d'armée
complet équilibré moderniser un modèle
d'armée cohérent et capables d'agir le
précédent quinquennat a permis un effort
sans précédent depuis la fin de la
guerre froide pour nous armer nous avons
respecté l'exécution de la loi de
programmation militaire nous avons
moderniser nos infrastructures nous
n'est un renouvellement massif de nos
équipements et lancer les grands
programmes d'avenir comme celui du
nouveau porte avions nous devons
maintenant poursuivre et amplifier cet
investissement prochainement le
président de la république annoncera les
contours d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire
il donnera une vision et un cap à nos
armées
comme à notre industrie de défense en
tirant tous les enseignements de
l'engagement de nos forces et de la
coopération avec d'autres armes et nous
tiendrons notre rôle nous agirons en
cohérence avec nos ambitions européennes
et nos alliés de l'otan nous devrons
aussi fortifier la résilience de la
nation et par l'accroissement de la
réserve par des actions auprès de notre
jeunesse par le travail sur la mémoire
par l'attention portée aux anciens
combattants nous renforcerons le lien
armée nation
la france sous l'impulsion du président
de la république devra enfin tenir toute
sa place sur la scène internationale
cela veut dire plus d'efforts en matière
de solidarité internationale
une ambition accrue pour les défis
globaux comme la santé ou le changement
climatique
cela vous de venir poursuivre le
renouvellement de notre relation avec
l'afrique par le dialogue par les
partenariats par le travail de mémoire
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je viens de vous présenter l'ambition
que porte mon gouvernement
je voulais dit elle est le socle de
notre travail à venir
mais les moyens de l'atteindre pourront
être enrichie amender
les échanges nourris que j'ai menées
avec les groupes de cette assemblée me
le montre nous avons les moyens et la
volonté de nous retrouver autour de
valeurs et d'objectifs communs
de construire ensemble de bâtir
sa collègue
[Musique]
nous avons les moyens et la volonté de
nous retrouver autour de valeurs et
d'objectifs communs de construire
ensemble et de porter des majorités
d'idées
l'heure n'est pas à nous conter mais à
nous parler
[Applaudissements]
la confiance ne se décrète pas a priori
elles se font jour à texte a pretext
projet après projet car nous
travaillerons en bonne foi et en bonne
intelligence
comme nous le demandent les français
devant chaque défi nous devrons nous
poser la question
voulons-nous bloquer ou voulons-nous
construire
7 en fonction de cela qu'on est français
nous jugeront
les enjeux devant nous sont immenses
mais je suis confiante et déterminée
notre pays est celui de tous les
possibles
celui qui à surmonter les crises une à
une avec force et solidarité celui qui
refuse la fatalité
celui où la promesse républicaine peut
et doit avoir un sens et une réalité
cette conviction je la tiens de mon
histoire car si je suis ici devant vous
première ministre de la france je le
dois à la république
c'est elle
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant en pupilles de la nation alors
que j'étais cet enfant dont le père
n'était jamais vraiment revenu des camps
c'est elle qui m'a montré que le travail
peut déjouer les destin tracé et qui m'a
donné un métier
c'est elle qui me guide et me pousse
dans mon engagement elle à qui je veux
rendre un peu de ce qu'elle m'a donné
c'est la république qui a ouvert la voie
à tant de femmes avant moi je pense à
irène joliot curie suzanne lacore et
cécile cécile breivik première femme
membre d'un gouvernement en 1936 sous le
front populaire
je pense aux 33 première femme à faire
leur entrée dans cet hémicycle au
lendemain de la libération
je pense à simone veil dont la force et
le courage
l'inspiration public
je pense à idées de cresson première
femme à accéder aux fonctions de
première ligne
[Applaudissements]
et
je sais dans cette assemblée présidée
pour la première fois par une femme
et comme chaque femme sur ses bancs ce
que je dois à toutes celles qui ont
ouvert le chemin avant nous je crois à
la force de l'exemple et le combat
continuera jusqu'à ce que l'égalité ne
pose plus de questions
j'ai partagé avec vous un peu de mon
histoire mais l'histoire dans la
république c'est celle de toutes les
françaises et de tous les français
la france notre france c'est celle des
enseignants qui donnent des visages et
des noms à la transmission et à
l'émancipation
la france notre france c'est celle des
soignants qui ne comptent pas leurs
heures n'ont reculé devant aucun effort
pendant plus de deux années de pandémie
celle des travailleurs de la deuxième
ligne qui ont assuré la continuité de
notre économie celle des commerçants qui
ont été exemplaires et ont tenu
la france notre france c'est celle de
cette jeunesse qui nous met devant nos
responsabilités
s'engage pour le climat prête à se
battre pour notre destin commun
la france notre france c'est celle des
créateurs des entrepreneurs des
travailleurs des fonctionnaires des
artisans des agriculteurs
c'est celle qui vient en aide à ceux qui
en ont besoin qui ne laisse personne sur
le côté étant toujours la main c'est
celle de la salade solidarité de
l'engagement et de la volonté
c'est aussi celle des craintes que nous
devons écouter des peurs auxquelles nous
devons répondre et aussi parfois des
colères que nous devons apaiser
cette france c'est la nôtre alors soyons
à sa hauteur à la hauteur des françaises
et des français
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
politique s'ouvre nous allons l'écrire
ensemble alors devant vous je m'engage à
partager les enjeux et les contraindre à
vous faire part de nos feuilles de route
et des différentes voir que nous
pourrions en traités je m'engage à ne
jamais rompre le fil du dialogue avec
les groupes parlementaires avec les
forces vives avec les françaises et les
français je m'engage à bâtir des
compromis ambitieux sans compromission
sur les valeurs des solutions concrètes
des majorités de projets et d'idées les
français ont sonné l'heure de la
responsabilité
ils seront au rendez vous nous avons
toutes et tous une part à prendre nous
avons tout pour réussir
bâtir ensemble nous y parviendrons je
vous remercie
28 de discours d'elisabeth borne à
l'assemblée nationale pour son discours
de politique générale bonjour carmet
bonjour rédacteur en chef au figaro
magazine évidemment on va débriefer tout
ce qui s'est dit parce que en 1h28 on a
le temps on vient dans un instant on
écoute quand même l'ambiance à
l'assemblée nationale on regarde ce qui
se passe parce que c'est intéressant les
réactions des députés
donc nous allons maintenant
donner la parole à madame la présidente
berger pour le groupe renaissance
voilà oui on explique parce qu'après le
discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth dans chaque groupe va venir
parler à un moment ça va commencer par
bergé qui est présidente du groupe
renaissance à l'assemblée 50 minutes
elle à orbey rejet donc après leurs 28
derniers avaient d'abord don va avoir
droit à 50 minutes d'horreur berger
avant d'avoir marine le pen notamment
avec le national 15 minutes c'est bien
ça bon karl intéressante cette fin de
discours sur les femmes avec cette voix
un peu chevrotante c'est peut-être ça
qu'on retiendra oui parce que forcément
un discours de politique générale comme
son nom l'indiqué c'est forcément
quelque chose qui reste général mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que elisabeth
borgne a tenté de fendre l'armure sur la
fin de son discours oui en parlant de
son parcours c'était un moment peut-être
qu'ils étaient attendus un des moments
forts parce que ben vous le soulignez
elle avait cette voie un peu chevrotante
on je pense qu'on l'aurait eue à moins
parce que elle a évoqué son père dont
elle dit qu'il n'est jamais vraiment
revenu des camps qui mord plus tard
quand elle avait 16 ans elle même donc
était pupille de la nation et elle a
expliqué tout ce qu'elle devait à la
république et ça ça fait partie des
moments forts de son discours l'autre
moment fort a été à peu près au même
à peu près au même instant quand elle a
évoqué les femmes ils ont précédé et là
c'est incroyable parce que je trouve que
ça en dit long sur les difficultés
qu'elle va avoir sur la suite c'est à
dire qu'à gauche oui on a observé
l'hémicycle ah oui oui parce que ce qui
était intéressant c'est de voir qui
applaudirent est qui ce le vrai au
moment où le groupe renaissance allait
s'élever elle a évoqué les premières
femmes ministres de 1936 premier
ministre mai 1936 le front populaire de
léon de morlaix à la gauche où il ya des
communistes et des socialistes
elle a évoqué les femmes ministres en
1945 1945 quand même la libération là
aussi il ya des communistes elle a
évoqué le nom de simone veil simone veil
c'est quelqu'un qui a passé son projet
de loi grâce aux voix de la gauche elle
a évoqué il dit crise inouïe sur qualité
la première fin sur première ministre
socialiste socialiste et pourtant tous
les bancs de gauche ne se sont pas levés
et n'ont pas applaudi ça en dit long sur
l'état d'esprit de cette partie de
l'hémicycle et comme dans son discours
ça si on évoque le fond et l'autre
partie où elle appelait au dialogue et
les dealers n'est pas à se compter mais
à se parler oui ça sent bien que ça va
être difficile de se parler à partir du
moment où ou quand même elle évoque des
figures consensuelles à gauche des
moments de l'histoire de france où la
gauche et était présente dans des
gouvernements eh bien ils applaudissent
même pas on écoutera certaines réactions
allez on écoute un instant nicolas
dupont aignan après ce discours de
d'elisabeth
cela veut dire qu'en réalité elle fait
semblant de bâtir ensemble mais elle
déroule au programme débats neuf mois
c'est vraiment ne pas tenir compte des
suffrages les élections c'est le partant
de la bri une proposition
pour moi je serai
du problème de son nom va retrouver
nicolas dupont aignan et tous les autres
parce que ça nous intéresse ses
premières réactions à la sortie alors
qu'est ce qu'on retiendra sur le fond on
a parlé un peu de la forme là de
personnalités d'elisabeth bord vous
m'avez dit hors antenne en elle et l'apa
s'est fendu l'armure bon on en reparlera
sur le fond sur son projet qu'est ce
qu'on retiendra alors on retiendra à mon
avis que c'est un discours général mais
j'allais dire cette émission impossible
pour elisabeth bornes qui n'est pas tom
cruise
j'avais remarqué vous aviez remarqué way
et le corps était dans un avion ça me
ferait rire à sa décharge parce qu'au
fond elle ne pouvait pas faire un autre
discours à partir d'un élan ou d'emblée
elle dit qu'elle va rechercher un accord
à l'assemblée nationale parce qu'elle
n'a pas la majorité absolue et que elle
va essayer d'obtenir l'accord des autres
groupes d'une partie des autres groupes
de l'assemblée elle ne peut pas faire un
discours en disant voilà tout ce que je
vais faire en étant très précise et si
je prends l'exemple comme de la retraite
elle a dit qu'il faudrait travailler
progressivement un peu plus longtemps
mais elle ne dit pas oui elle ne reprend
pas le programme des meilleurs mc rond
qui est baissier quelle forme en 65 ans
puis ensuite 64 ans elle ne rentre pas
dans la nuit parce qu'elle sur la
retraite par points ne sais pas comment
ça sera fait parce que si elle commence
à rentrer dans le détail elle arrive
avec un projet ficelé à et donc elle se
met déjà à dos les oppositions d'un côté
de l'autre voilà donc comme elle dit les
a pas ficelé ça ne sera pas à prendre ou
à laisser mais il y aura une négociation
indispensable au fond elles laissent
tous les champs ouverts mais ce faisant
elle encourt la critique et on voit bien
dans les réactions va les entendre
qu'ils aient bas en fait on a une
feuille de route mais on n'a pas les
étapes on sait pas exactement où on va
mais elle ne pouvait pas faire autrement
à partir du moment où elle veut
rechercher pas forcément un consensus
mais au moins élargie la majorité comme
l a dit des majorités de projet vous
réagissez sur youtube sur tweets sur
lefigaro.fr je prends tout vocation je
les transmets à carl meeus elle a
commencé par cela puis elle a saupoudré
tout son discours avant de finir par
cela bâtir ensemble
elle a beaucoup parlé aux députés de
l'opposition n'ont et en les mettant
presque face à leurs responsabilités
oui il allait voir un nous si vous
faites pas votre travail avec nous on va
bien le montrer aux français bat
exactement ta son voile c'est bien le
président l'a dit elle le répète l'enjeu
c'est on essaye on va apprendre en
marchant on essaye de construire des
majorités nous on tend la main on est de
bonne volonté c'est ce qu'ils disent à
vous deux d'abord nous parler de dire ce
que vous voulez de voir ce qu'on peut
faire et si vous ne voulez pas bon on
prend effectivement les français à
témoin et dans une deuxième étape
éventuellement on l'est on leur donne
reste de la responsabilité de recomposer
une majorité ce qui est intéressant ce
qui était amusant c'est
les noms des présidents de groupe alors
voilà oui j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi à
expliquer pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
voilà parce qu'elle a reçu les
présidents de groupe avant de faire ce
discours de politique générale et à
chaque étape de son discours elle a cité
alors aux dix premiers c'est olivier
marleix c'est une envie et merline des
finances publiques voilà ont elles fait
un laïus sur les finances publiques elle
dit je sais que vous êtes d'accord
président marc l'ex nous en avons parlé
ensemble et là alors évidemment avec la
drire chez tout le monde chez beaucoup
de gens en se disant oh la la il essaye
de le coincer tout ça mais après elle va
citer tous les autres oui il y en a que
deux qu'elle ne va pas citer et en
suisse ont d'ailleurs tous les deux que
gérald darmanin a exclu presque d'un
champ républicain en disant que c'était
des ennemis c'est la france insoumise
présidée par mathilde panneaux et
le rassemblement national présidé par le
par marine le pen mais tous les autres
ont été cités à des moments différents
oui sur des thèmes d'après si elle a eu
une très longue partie sur l'écologie
julien bayou et serial châtelain des
logis vert qui sont coprésidents hop
elle les a cités avec toujours cette
phrase nous en avons parlé ensemble
sous-entendu voyez on discute exactement
en tout cas moi je vous ai sais pas je
vous ai compris mais je voyais un sens
du jeu j'ai compris votre message je le
reprends à mon compte et puis pour
montrer aux français attention ça vous
êtes d'accord donc ne fait pas n'importe
quoi et ne soyez pas dans une opposition
qui ne sert à rien exactement ne soyez
pas
ne bloquez pas comme elle l'a dit le
voit voulons nous bloquer ou
voulons-nous construire l mais là le
j'allais dire le le contrat sur la table
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que on
l'attendait au tournant elle n'a jamais
par définition fait ce genre d'exercice
c'est comme ça en disant l'espoir
l'armure est ce qu'on va voir de quel
bois elle se chauffe voilà les fait
exactement alors vous savez un discours
de politique générale on n'oublie pas ce
que c'est tous les 5 3 à 4 ans tout le
monde oublie ce passage là mais c'est
jamais quelque chose de flamboyant passé
il faut citer tout le monde
allez vous voulez oui bon équipe quelle
qu'elle soit qu'elle veut bien écouter
deux oppositions et qu'elle est prête à
tout
au compromis allah dieu d'ailleurs
prononcé ce mot de compromis de bave pas
mal de fois sauf que les compromis
doivent se faire sur le programme d'
emmanuel macron donc j'ai envie de vous
dire que aucune leçon n'a été tirée des
élections législatives et du résultat de
ces élections législatives elle a
reconnu avoir une majorité relative si
elle a pas de majorité absolue c'est
justement parce que les français ne
voulaient pas du programme d' emmanuel
macron très vite dans le discours il ne
vous aura pas échappé qu'est venu sur la
table le retour à l'équilibré des
finances publiques
c'est d'une année indécence je trouve
assez rare au moment où la question
principale des françaises et des
français c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat qu'ils sont en train de faire
des arbitrages pour savoir s'ils vont
pouvoir partir en vacances ils vont
pouvoir se payer un resto pendant leurs
vacances et on leur peur on leur parle
déjà de retour à l'équilibré des
finances publiques tout ça à tout ça
sans vouloir mettre à contribution bien
sûr ceux qui ont fait quand même des
surprofits pendant la crise j'ai envie
de vous dire tout ça pour ça tout ça
pour ça d'ailleurs quand on regarde
quelques unes des annonces on a là des
configurations de l'allocation adulte
handicapé on à la nationalisation d'edf
et des choses qu'on a proposé sans cesse
pendant cinq ans aucune écoute
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'ils ont
changé de braquet à 180 degrés mais ces
deux annonces qui sont évidemment
beaucoup de temps perdu pour les
personnes qui en situation de handicap
ont subi la conjugue anisation des
années 80 dit handicapé et puis
évidemment beaucoup de temps perdu aussi
sur le climat on disait elle elle plaide
le compromis mais c'est surtout beaucoup
de poncifs si on compare c'est
finalement assez similaire au discours
d'edouard philippe sur le climat et nous
annonce une espèce de grand débat elle a
oublié qu'ils avaient une convention
dont le gouvernement n'avait tiré aucune
leçon donc finalement on dirait retour à
la case départ et où sont les français
et où sont les attentes des concitoyens
et des concitoyens auquel nous on
propose des solutions 1 la hausse des
salaires on n'a rien entendu là-dessus
donc nous on sort évidemment déçu de ce
discours de la première ministre assez
laborieux et surtout assez long sans
qu'on ait appris grand chose
on vient d'entendre philippe brun
socialiste et puis et puis c'était marie
christine pires bonne socialiste aussi
là nous plaisent pas forcément satisfait
on s'y attendait ses discours
on s'attendrait toute façon alors là on
peut déjà
ah non c'est ce qui va se passer
effectivement à la nuque s'ils vont dire
ça va pas du tout dans le bon sens il
l'avait commencé à lire avant les élèves
audio ce sont les méta de lannux 1 ce
sont les socialistes oui attendez de
voir et les filles puisque même avant
même le discours de politique générale
adrien quatre noms se disait que ce
gouvernement n'était pas légitime donc
vous voyez le niveau
ça c'est vu d'ailleurs dans les
mythiques puisqu'ils n'ont pas arrêté de
vociférer d'essayer de l'attitude très
différente de la gauche la droite de la
droite
expliquez-nous quand même passé
stratégique tout ça mais évidemment là
le groupe de marine le pen a été très
sage l'intéressent cassandra
voilà montrant qu' ils veulent est à
montrer affiché un comportement
responsable en tout cas ne pas faire les
zouaves comme font les filles qui
vocifèrent qui interrompent entre rufin
corbières et tout et tout les autres
ils ont décidé de prendre le la position
totalement inverse ce qui ne veut pas
dire elles ne seront pas habilités c'est
ça exactement mais ce qu'il veut pas
dire qu'ils seront pas opposant vous
allez voir dans les réactions ça sera ça
ne va pas dans le bon sens elle n'a pas
parlé ou très peu d'immigration la
sécurité c'était plutôt à la fin ça a
duré moins longtemps que le pouvoir
d'achat tout ça ce sont des petits
marqueur sur lesquels ils insisteront
évidemment elle a commencé isabelle
borne
son discours en parlant du pouvoir
d'achat évidemment puis très rapidement
elle est arrivée au travail travail et
aux retraites je voudrais qu'on parle de
ça nous devrons travailler
progressivement un peu plus longtemps
applaudissements d'un côté sifflet de
l'autre c'est le moment où il ya eu une
petite bronca vous à l'amuser au début
ça la fait sourire et puis et venant
elle s'est retournée vers yale pour une
pub et qui était au dessus d'elle pour
lui dire est là il faut quand même
mettre des barrières pour que puisse
continuer oui voilà c'est là qu'on voit
que
c'est pas ces pacs il mais il ya un
manque d'expérience à la tête pour
l'instant de l'assemblée nationale
effectivement bah oui parce qu'il faut
tout de suite mettre le holà surtout
dans une assemblée avec comme ça autant
de nuls ces deux allées fille dont on
sait qu'ils vont chercher à déstabiliser
les orateurs et donc il faut tout de
suite mettre le holà bon après il ya les
brawn puis elle l'a fait mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
arrivés à déstabiliser et les abbés de
mort dont on le disait tout à l'heure
non seulement vous faites un bilan vous
dit elle a plutôt été bonne pas
déstabiliser aucun moment et ben moi je
trouve que sur la forme elle était
plutôt même très bonne voire habile
parce que
et alors vous attendiez à ça avant
on ne savait pas s'attendait à ce que
nous étions la connaissent pas elle ne
l'a jamais fait on savait que l avait un
parcours
républicain et qu'il fallait qu'elle en
parle est-ce qu'elle ait osé le faire
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est très
pudique qui n'aime pas se mettre en
avant et vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
elle avait d'ailleurs la voix qui
tremble est à ce moment là parce que
elle doit se forcer mais elle est très
habile parce que elle connaît à l'avance
la réaction de ses opposants et donc
quand elle apparaît de la retraite elle
savait que ça serait la bronca chez elle
est fille quand elle a cité le nom
d'olivier marc l'ex pour lui dire nous
avons travaillé ensemble on voyait bien
qu elle souriait donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a anticipé qui savait que des choses
allaient arriver ça c'est sur la forme
sur le fond c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure un discours de politique
générale c'est forcément toujours trop
long et toujours très ennuyeux mais
aussi de sortir de de généralités on
peut répondre à philippe humbert sur
youtube qui nous dit bornes discours
ennuyeux et sans intérêt sans intérêt je
suis pas sûr mais on peut comprendre
l'ennui en 1h28 quand on n'est pas
forcément habitué à ces longs discours à
l'assemblée parfois très techniques ça
s'entend ça s'entend mais je reviens sur
ce que je disais au début c'est
malheureusement le cadre de ce discours
qui entraîne cet ennui mais cette fois
ci ils étaient renforcées par le fait
qu'ils avaient de mort n'ayant pas la
majorité devant construire des majorités
de projets elle ne pouvait pas avoir d
des précisions
sur les projets de loi elle pouvait pas
en gros faire un rocard en 88 il
commence à dire voilà je vous annonce on
va je vais faire le rmi je vais faire un
certain nombre de choses
parce que lui il pouvait se permettre de
rentrer dans le détail mais même s'il
avait pas la majorité il était tout
proche il était tout proche et il savait
l'hémicycle était à ce moment là quand
même nettement plus modéré il y avait
une opposition communiste et une
opposition à trois déciles entre il
n'y avait pas ces deux radicalités là et
et c'était quelqu'un presque on l'a vu
plus tard mais qui qui avait une grande
marge de manoeuvre par rapport à un
françois mitterrand qu'il l'a laissé
faire c'était presque une sorte de
cohabitation si on peut dire là elle
doit appliquer le programme du président
de la république en le mot des rangs
avec les discussions qu'elle va entamer
à l'assemblée nationale donc c'était
compliqué de rentrer dans les détails
encore une fois on l'a dit tout à
l'heure mais selon l'exemple d'être la
réforme des retraites et parce que ce
n'est pas allé plus loin c'était la
question c'était là que vous voulez vous
emmener quand on a vu les réactions tout
au long des thèmes qu'ils allaient
aborder c'est vraiment là dessus qu'ils
aient eu le plus d'effervescence est ce
que c'est ça le prochain grand débat est
ce que quand on voit ça on se dit que
cette réforme des retraites elle ne peut
pas être menée bah dis donc ça va être
très compliqué ça va être un des propose
qu'on écoute bien il sandrine rousseau
parce que c'est une personnalité
la planification écologique à une mort
radicalité mondiaux alors qu'il avait
aucune espèce de mesures qui était
radical dans celle qui était annoncée
donc oui il ya des mots mais ça vraiment
l'air d'emmanuel macron et de ses
ministres a toujours été celle ci s'est
d'ailleurs d'utiliser des mots des mots
choc des mots qui sont dans le débat
politique mais que ça ne se transforme
jamais en actions là on le voit on est
resté sur un modèle productiviste de
croissance à tous crins d'augmentation
de la consommation on va dans le mur on
augmente la quand le pouvoir d'achat
pour augmenter les quantités consommées
moi je suis pour qu'on augmente le
pouvoir d'achat des personnes les plus
faibles mais pas qu'on réduise les
impôts de ceux qui sont les plus riches
en france là on vous continuent dans le
modèle qui est un modèle de
ruissellement un modèle libéral un
modèle de destruction si des services
publics parce que faut savoir lire entre
ses lignes quand elle dit que on va
continuer par exemple a buté contre la
fracture numérique c'est aussi une
manière de ne pas mettre des agents
publics dans les territoires qui sont
les plus défavorisés et sur l'hôpital
par exemple elle n'a rien annoncé
d'important alors que les pics l'hôpital
est vraiment au bord de l'effondrement
cette motion de censure aussi comme un
coup de com une façon de faire parler de
vous allez c'est une manière de marquer
que nous ne sommes pas sur le même
modèle de société notre modèle de
société c'est un modèle de société
d'égalité et pas d'égalité des chances
on a l'impression qu'on va tous jouer au
loto là mais en fait c'est une égalité
de droits inégaux les inégalités de
réussite et puis surtout une bifurcation
un changement une transformation
écologique d'ampleur là on est encore
sur un modèle productiviste enfin il
faut bien comprendre que c'est ce que le
giec nous entier ma de changer le giec
nous dit on est dans une situation qui
est catastrophique il ya des glaciers
entier qui ces fonds il ya des orages de
grêle ya des inondations on est de
catastrophe écologique en catastrophe
écologique et pour autant on fait comme
si on devait continuer avec une
augmentation de la croissance avec
l'augmentation de la consommation
vraiment nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur
de l'enjeu
il fallait reporter match dans tous les
bus bondés dont la sandero dit tout le
gouvernement et masquer certains députés
certains députés voilà sandrine rousseau
convient d'entendre on entendu beaucoup
et on a vu beaucoup décider des députés
de gauche on n'a pas encore vu ce droite
et du rassemblement national on verra on
écoutera leur leur réaction bon pas de
surprise dans ce que nous dit sandrine
rousseau aucune surprise quand bien même
elisabeth bornes annonce une
nationalisation d'edf leur mot de
nationalisation ne l'avait pas entendu
depuis très longtemps dans un
gouvernement on se souvient plutôt de de
privatisation ou d'ouverture d'une
ouverture de capital pas utiliser le mot
nationale oui en prendre le contrôle à
100% de guerre si les mots ont un sens
oui
c'est quand même après à peu près ça
il ya la planification écologique mais
on voit bien que ça ne sera jamais assez
on voit bien que c'est pas du côté de
l'efi et peut-être d'une partie des
écolos purs et durs qui va y avoir des
ouvertures pendant tout le quinquennat
ça c'est évident mais le gouvernement le
sait les consultations ont permis
justement de lever ces hypothèques là
c'est plutôt du côté
des socialistes qui n'était pas pro nuxe
qui ont été élus ils sont une demi
douzaine et ils ont déjà dit d'ailleurs
qu'il venait pas la motion de censure
est peut-être au fil du temps sur
certains projets sur sur quelques
discussions des membres du parti
socialiste du groupe socialiste qui
pourront là aussi se détache et
peut-être d'un
extrémisme de l efi killer pedra la
réforme des retraites allait je vous me
répondez là dessus on était coupé c'est
de ma faute je vous coupe mon cher karl
la réforme des retraites oui ça va être
difficile quand on a juste con ce qui
s'est passé là l'assemblée lorsque
elisabeth borne à évoquer la question
oui bah c'est ce qu'on dit c'est à
l'heure c'est mission impossible sauf
qu'ils avaient deux bornes n'est pas tom
cruise je le répète parce que vous étiez
d'accord avec moi là
et non ça va être très très compliqué
alors après on sait qu'il ya des outils
parlementaire qui lui permettent de
faire passer les réformes à l'assemblée
le l'article 49 3
la question c'est ce qu'ils voudront sur
un sujet aussi sensible
passé par un 49,3 alors même que on voit
bien que dans la rue d'abord dans les
sondages les français sont opposés à un
report telle que le président le voulait
à 65 65 ans donc est-ce que si c'est
moins loin est ce que les français ils
seront toujours opposée est ce qu'il y
aura des manifestations monstres dans la
rue qui
provoqueront des blocages ce qu'on sait
de toute façon c'est que c'est pas le
texte qui va arriver tout de suite le
texte qui va arriver là la semaine
prochaine c'est un texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat que pour les retraites il va y
avoir d'abord des discussions et ensuite
elle a ouvert quand même des points
alors qu'ils sont des points classique
sur la carrière longue sur la pénibilité
mais qui sont des points
sur lesquels les syndicats sont
sensibles et notamment la cfdt donc on
va voir parce qu'elle l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils allaient avoir
des discussions avec les partenaires
sociaux on va voir est ce que ces
discussions seront plus efficaces que
celles qui ont eu lieu dans le
quinquennat précédent ça ça va être un
des enjeux aussi de des mois à venir
autre thème largement évoqué c'est
peut-être la partie la plus longue sur
sur l'écologie sa durée est presque 15
minutes entre tous alors il ya parlé de
la cohésion des territoires elle a parlé
de l'énergie mais très grosse partie sur
l'écologie c'est vrai avant le entre
deux tours se souvient de ce discours d'
emmanuel macron à marseille qui avait
placé cette première ministre ministre
de l'écologie finalement oui qui
administre qui vont s'occuper de l'aigle
et de planification écologique qui
dépendent d'elle et elle a dit on veut
elle veut faire de la france la première
grande nation à sortir des énergies
fossiles
là effectivement on est obligé quand
même de dire oui il ya des mots
maintenant passons aux actes parce que
pour depuis cinq ans
c'est un peu d'ailleurs le déficit du
gouverneur gouvernement précédent c'est
que il n'y avait pas beaucoup d'actes
même s'il ya eu quelques mesures qui ont
été prises mais on n'a pas les grands de
mesure les grandes lois qui vont faire
prendre conscience aux français qu'on a
qu'on a opéré un véritable tournant
allez on enchaîne un peu les thématiques
marquantes
on a également parlé alors c'est arrivé
tard au bout de 50 minutes de discours
de la santé après presque trois ans et
demi et la crise actuelle aux urgences
c'est arrivé tard mais il a fallu en
parler et là aussi ça cristallise les
débats notamment sur la réintégration
des soignants en fait c'est selon maxime
au moment où il ya eu là la bronca à
l'assemblée nationale c'est sur les
retraites et sur la santé quand elle a
voulu rendre hommage aux soignants et là
effectivement sur les bancs de la gauche
et notamment de l efi il ya eu une
grosse bronca ils ont claqué les
pupitres enfin le système habituel pour
faire du bruit ce que j'allais revenir à
demande la même chose n'a pas bougé n'a
pas bougé bien sûr c'est ça qui est très
le monde la même chose la réintégration
des soignants à chaque fois en fait vous
dites ça arrivait au bout de la 50e
minute mais parce que l a10 le premier
déficit le pouvoir d'achat parce
qu'aujourd'hui les français disent que
leur première préoccupation c'est le
pouvoir d'achat elle a évoqué le
deuxième défi c'est l'urgence écologique
parce que là aussi elle ne peut pas ne
pas l'évoquer et du coup c'est arrivé
effectivement en troisième position
ce problème de la santé elle a rendu
hommage à jean castex elle a parlé
plusieurs fois des territoires là aussi
à la saupoudrer son discours sur cette
question des territoires elle veut se
mettre dans sa ligne à jean castex on le
sait lui l'élu de terrain c'est pour ça
qu'ils emmanuel macron est allé le
chercher oui et puis il ya cette idée de
d'expérimenter 2-2 au près dans les
territoires et voir comment ça marche et
comme elle le dit on fonctionne pas de
la même sphère de la même façon à paris
que dans une petite ville
une moins grande ville ou à dire
pourquoi avec ses villes moyennes comme
rodez ou castrais la cité cayenne bon
voilà et donc pourquoi rodez et castres
n'avait pas d'autres
enfants on peut en prendre d'autres web
allez-y vous attend cherbourg tiens
voilà par ailleurs
si vous voulez qu'on s'y dévoile non
mais voilà on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
on peut plus faire des lois qui vont
s'appliquer de la même façon sur tout le
territoire ça avait déjà été une des
préoccupations dans le gouvernement
précédent jean castex le le disait
souvent hélas ils vont vraiment le
coup dit elle ils vont essayer de mettre
en place alors des annonces un peu plus
concrète un peu plus marquantes je donne
pêle mêle un ca n'a parfois rien à voir
l'état va donc participer et prendre
100% du capital d'edf pôle emploi
devient france travail
vouloir dire nous travaillerons
collectivement plus longtemps ça c'est
la grande phrase peut être à retenir le
système de location de voiture verte en
leasing est ce que c'est ça aussi un
discours de politique générale des
points très précis comme ça sur des
dossiers pour rendre les choses plus
concrètes pour les français qui
regardent donc ces points là ce sont les
points 2 du programme de d'emmanuel
macron sur lequel au fond elle peut
s'avancer parce que globalement ça peut
faire consensus donc ça c'est énorme
demande pourquoi nationaliser edf ça va
convaincre les français c'est vrai que
les français se disent plutôt pourquoi
pas edf l'état je suis sûr d'avoir mon
énergie pas cher voilà voilà l'idée
c'est justement de pouvoir contrôler
les approvisionnements le
l'énergie est essayée jeu de de faire
cette politique qui va dans un sens que
veut le gouvernement et c'est plus
facile si on contrôle les entreprises
donc c'est c'est plus dans un aspect de
stratégie globale pour pouvoir aboutir à
ça allez on enchaîne on continue elle à
elle un peu fait le bilan aussi
elisabeth bornand il ya un discours de
politique générale c'est pour dire ce
qu'on va faire ensuite elle a beaucoup
parlé des anciennes mesures vous trouvez
pas que elle ne s'est peut-être pas
assez projeter non je pense qu'elle a
voulu montrer que tous aillent dans un
s'inscrit dans un continuum c'est à dire
qu'il sait pas il n'y a pas une rupture
entre le quai les deux anciens premiers
ministres même si elle a cité que jean
castex et elle que tout ça a une
cohérence et elle est obligée de le
faire et bien de macron a été réélu il
n'a pas été réélu avec un programme
complètement orthogonale par rapport à
ce qu'ils faisaient avant donc elle est
obligée de l'inscrit dans un dans un
continuum même si la situation politique
n'est plus la même ils ne sont plus avec
une majorité absolue avec plus de 300
dégoûté qui peuvent faire la pluie et le
beau temps qu'on n'écoute pas forcément
et on est obligé d'en tenir compte et
surtout elle l'a suffisamment répété et
c'est là aussi où on peut dire peut-être
qu'il ya il ya des injonctions
contradictoires c'est à dire qu'elle
avait caché comme objectif que la france
revienne en dessous des 3% de déficit en
2027 que
commencer à réduire la dette en 2026 ah
oui mais j'avais noté beaucoup de moyens
point d'exclamation et elles sont les
propositions d'économies lagraula et
surtout il autre annonce par annonce
quelque chose que l'on nous dit depuis
longtemps il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
d'impôts il ya même plus tôt d'ailleurs
la confirmation que la redevance télé
sera supprimée qu'on continuera sur la
baisse de la taxe d'habitation ou la
suppression pour les 20% qui conduit à
les payer mais donc effectivement vous
avez raison il y avait beaucoup de
choses sur des dépenses ou des moindres
recettes mais rien sur qu'est-ce qui va
remplir les caisses sachant qu'on
s'interdit aujourd'hui de
d'augmenter les impôts oui alors on en
est toujours sûr c'est la croissance qui
va nous permettre de créer des emplois
et donc on va réduire les déficits on
voit bien aujourd'hui que la situation
économique est pas si simple les taux
d'intérêt augmentent l'inflation
continue à augmenter donc là il ya
peut-être des contradictions dont on
verra le résultat au moment du budget et
à la rentrée quand on fait un tour à
l'assemblée nationale salle des quatre
colonnes c'est là où on a vu passer tous
ses députés vincent rosereau journaliste
au figaro live évidemment que vous
connaissez bien est avec toi indirects
vincent alors on a vu passer beaucoup de
personnalités de gauche est ce qu'il y a
eu aussi des personnalités de droite du
rassemblement national
quelle est l'ambiance dans cette salle
des quatre colonnes et quels sont les
différents discours
c'est un peu l'effervescence décès de la
suite du discours comme on pouvait s'y
attendre on a surtout vu des députés de
denilson rosso qui a longtemps parlé à
la presse qui continuent de le faire
elle est un peu plus loin là bas elle a
dénoncé effectivement le discours d
isabelle borne pas assez radicale à son
goût même si et alors elle a reproché à
certains termes d'être mal utilisé
d'être sorti en fait de l'idée qu'elle
elle se faisait de ses ternes antoine
méo mans autre député de lannux était là
nicolas dupont aignan à jour a aussi
pardon donner son avis en disant qu'il
ne pouvait pas voter qui auraient voté
la motion de censure c'est ce qu'il va
faire en tout cas c'est un peu libéré
sans cela on attend les prochains
députés qu'ils vont qui vont arriver
d'ici quelques minutes on voit on voit
fabien roussel derrière vous également
alors que marine le pen prend la parole
en ce moment une dans l'hémicycle on
vous la fera écouter dans un instant oui
on a écouté vincent évidemment beaucoup
de critiques karl mais il ya aussi des
moments d'unanimité dirait une tendance
dans ce discours de politique générale
oui locales dites moi il y en a eu 1 au
moment où elle a rendu hommage aux
soldats français est là tout le monde
s'est levé et tout le monde a applaudi
donc on souligne suffisamment les
moments où la gauche n'a pas applaudi ou
a fait un brouhaha pour quand même aussi
remarquer que voilà quand il s'agit de
soldats français qui plus est mort pour
la patrie et bien là la représentation
nationale la plus grande salle on écoute
fabien roussel parce que là ça sonne
c'est l'expression oui fabien roussel
lui un membre de la nuque baisse un peu
divergents de tous les autres voir si
son discours est différent
c'était dans
à fabien roussel est ce qu'il s'en va ou
est-ce qu'il se met en place pour marina
leurs 200 à l'heure de retourner dans
l'hémicycle dommage on a raté fabien
roussel avoir c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites parce qu'effectivement on
sent poindre au sein de la nuit baisse
des divergences oui il ya des
divergences par son avant même les
élections au nom bien sûr on le sait il
ya des divergences de fond notamment sur
le nucléaire
sur plusieurs curseur comme sa sécurité
par mais il ya des divergences
exactement sur des expressions que
j'allais dire il l'a bien dit luynes
n'aurait pas employé c'était de
l'expression car employé est jean luc
mélenchon la police tue d'ailleurs il
avait deux bornes a eu le moment assez
fort ou on a bien vu qu'elle visait jean
luc mélenchon
sans le nommer je crois que je les ai
honte à ceux qui veulent dresser les
français contre ceux qui les protègent
on a bien compris qu'il parle exactement
base de jean-luc mélenchon et des siens
la police tue et ça venait avant ou
après honte à ceux qui attaquent les
policiers les gendarmes et là elle a été
très applaudie évidemment par par la
renaissance et on voit bien qui elle
visait mais donc ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir qu'il ya des aujourd'hui
c'est des fissures aujourd'hui ça reste
dans les mots mais ce qui va être
intéressant de voir c'est ce que dans
les textes que le gouvernement va
proposer est ce que là il y aura des
votes qui seront divergent entre les
communistes les socialistes les
écologistes et la france info me
guillaume tabard me disait avant le
discours si elle ne parle pas d'un thème
on pointera du doigt ce thème est ce
qu'il ya un thème qu'elle n'a pas évoqué
ou peu évoqué parce que là on a parlé
des grandes lignes de ce qui nous a
marqué qu est-ce qui
pas assez ressorti selon vous il ya
quelque chose qui lui sera sûrement
reproché notamment par la droite peut
être par l'extrême droite c'est que il
faut attendre la fin du discours pour
qu'elle parle de sécurité qu'elle parle
d'immigration et encore elle le fait à
travers juste les frontières et l'europe
et je suis même pas sûr que le mot sous
couvert de vérifier mais le mot
immigration et était vraiment prononcé
donc oui
il peut y avoir comme ça des c'est pas
un manque parce qu'il sait c'est dans le
discours mais ça montre que ce n'est pas
la priorité aujourd'hui la priorité elle
a mis le premier défi c'est le pouvoir
d'achat et cela dit ça correspond à ce
que disent les français aujourd'hui qui
mettent le pouvoir d'achat en
préoccupation numéro un merci beaucoup
car merci de m'avoir accompagné alors on
reste à l'assemblée nationale regarder
cette image de marine le pen qui prend
la parole c'est la principale opposante
un finalement on va écouter la fin de
son discours elisabeth bande la regarde
elle a remis son masque vous allez
pouvoir suivre tout ça et puis ça va
s'enchaîner chaque groupe présentera son
président qui viendra à la tribune juste
sous le perchoir de yale juan figer pour
s'exprimer et puis le débat continue
merci beaucoup car mais josh grande
journée de politique on continua sur ce
qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
suite au discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth bornes merci de nous avoir
suivi on reste ensemble il nous faut
retrouver une parole publique dans la
crédibilité à soir à l'autorité il nous
faut reconstruire l'état son autorité
ses moyens il nous faut redonner au pays
un projet collectif enthousiasmant ses
grands objectifs
corollaire indispensable du redressement
national
le groupe du rassemblement national les
fera valoir ici il défendra les grandes
priorités que ses électeurs lui ont
donné pour mission de promouvoir et dans
toute la mesure du possible de faire
appliquer retrouvé notre souveraineté en
se préservant d'une union européenne
prisonnière d'une dérive impériale qui
constitue la négation du droit des
peuples et des gens renouer avec une
représentation politique ou sociale
vraiment démocratique qui fasse que
chaque citoyen se sente représentée
revoir l'action diplomatique
sécuritaires sociales judiciaires et du
cac si vous repensez le modèle
économique mondialisé pour un modèle
basé sur le localisme les circuits
courts et la promotion des productions
locales et nationales bref un modèle
plus vertueux plus écologique plus
responsables se pencher sur les
conditions concrètes de vie des français
leur pouvoir d'achat leur santé leur
logement leur droit à la mobilité à la
liberté ouvrir des perspectives pour les
trente années qui viennent par la
redéfinition d'une grande politique
industrielle la mise en oeuvre de choix
énergétiques prospective dégager de
stupide a priori idéologiques
le rééquilibrage du territoire et la
recherche d'une plus grande harmonie
économique par une politique de de
métropolisation en faveur de la ruralité
nous mesurons la responsabilité que nous
ont confié les électeurs en nous plaçant
comme premier groupe d'opposition cette
désignation comme force d'opposition de
gouvernement c'est à dire comme force
d'alternance au pouvoir en place nous
honore évidemment vous l'avez compris
nous ne souhaitons pas être une position
d'obstruction mais de proposition pas
une position de principe qui
chercheraient à mettre le pouvoir à la
faute mais une force qui place l'intérêt
national au dessus des veines et
venimeuses agitation partisane
sur les principes qui sont les nôtres
vous nous trouverez toujours ferme selon
l'attitude du gouvernement réseau lui
soit à nouveau posée si les mesures vont
dans le mauvais sens soit à trouver des
voies de passage dès lors qu'ils en sont
pris en compte cela signifie par dans la
prise en considération de nos priorités
de nos motions et de nos amendements il
appartient donc au gouvernement de
décider du blocage ou du fonctionnement
institutionnel
si je préside a excusé moi j'ai quinze
minutes a failli être un autre
intervenant de l'arrivée des bleus qui
ne leur vient de toi moi merci non ça ne
sais pas si je suis intransigeant ce le
rayon de soleil parole ou l'irrespect
envers nos électeurs il en assumera
devant le pays la responsabilité pour
notre part nous sommes prêts à toute
éventualité
nous n'aurons pas à voter sur la
confiance puisque le gouvernement se
dérobe et nous influeront donc sur les
textes qui nous seront présentés au
premier rang desquels celui que les
français attendent avec espoir et
impatience celui sur le pouvoir d'achat
notre première décision a d'ailleurs
légitimement été de demander une
commission d' enquête sur les raisons de
l'inflation qui les frappe madame bob
vous ne pourrez pas faire comme si de
rien n'était vous ne pourrez pas faire
comme si rien n'avait changé le peuple a
voté
entendez le nous sommes ses
représentants entendez nous
je vous remercie
je vous précise que madame le pen vous
aviez un temps d'intervention dix
minutes donc vous l'avez largement
dépassé donc l'autre intervenant
monsieur loubet ne pourra pas intervenir
je donne la parole à madame la
présidente panneaux pour la france
insoumise
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre collègues le président a été
élu sans mandat voici venu sa première
ministre sans confiance ce mercredi 6
juillet est une date à marquer d'une
pierre noire pour la démocratie
madame elisabeth bornes vous devenez
officiellement la première ministre d'un
gouvernement minoritaire vous êtes bel
et bien chargé de conduire la politique
de la nation par le seul fait du prince
vous ne devez votre place qu'un
président de la république lui-même élu
par défaut
il faut le dire
l'exercice auquel nous nous prêtons ici
est une mascarade
nous parlerons chacun à la suite avant
que vous ne rendriez tranquillement à
matignon ainsi vous fait l'aveu de votre
faiblesse vous ne vous soumettez pas au
vote de confiance
de peur de ne pas l'obtenir jamais
depuis 30 ans une première ministre
c'était défilé ainsi
vous avez été battu aux élections
législatives
vous avez perdu 100 des 100 sièges vous
êtes classé dernière chef de
gouvernement d'europe en
représentativité populaire seuls 26 %
des votants et 12 % des inscrits se
réclame de votre parti aux dernières
élections mais vous faites comme si de
rien n'était dans ces circonstances
un vote de confiance s'imposer mais vous
avez choisi la fuite le mercredi 6
juillet restera comme ce jour où deux
nouveaux vous avez piétiné le vote des
français votre stratégie désormais c'est
sauve qui peut et vous êtes prêt à tout
jamais au compromis mais à toutes les
compromissions nous avons vu la semaine
dernière
l'étendue de votre forfait morales et
politiques tous sauf la nouvelle union
populaire était votre credo vous vous
êtes livrés à toutes sortes de deux
combinés de renvoi d'ascenseur le
rassemblement national s'y retirer de la
course à la présidence de l'assemblée
permettant à madame prendre privés
d'accéder à son trône le lendemain des
députés demorand
fondée par des cambistes 10dans de
l'assemblée vous cachez plus tôt la
peste brune que le contrôle fiscal quoi
de plus normal quand vous partagez un
programme libéral au service de
l'oligarchie
alors oui nous déposerons une motion de
défiance
c'est ce qui se produit lorsque
l'exécutif n'écoute que lui même il est
temps de vous apprendre le sens du mot
des groupes hbos cratie que vous
détestez et que vous ne tolérez que
lorsqu'elle vous est favorable en 1966
votre prédécesseur georges pompidou qui
s'était soustrait comme vous au vote de
confiance s'exprimer ainsi la lettre et
l'esprit de la constitution de 1958
volts en effet que le gouvernement soit
entièrement libre de demander ou non un
vote de confiance et qu'ils
appartiennent de préférence à
l'assemblée de mettre en jeu la
responsabilité ministérielle par la
procédure la plus normale est la mieux
adaptée je veux dire la motion de
censure
alors votre porte parole nous conseille
de vous écouter avant de préjugés de
quoi que ce soit nous vous avons écouté
madame la première ministre mais surtout
nous vous avons déjà vu à l'oeuvre vous
n'en n'êtes pas à votre premier méfait
vous avez été l'artisane zélé de la
casse du service public ferroviaire et
de la casse de l'assurance chômage qui a
permis de réaliser deux milliards
d'euros d'économies sur le dos des plus
pauvres vous n'avez jamais dévié vous
souhaitez toujours gouvernés contre le
peuple sauf que votre pouvoir est en
voie de décomposition
depuis le 19 juin 2022 vous avez tout
fait pour dissimuler votre pouvoir par
effraction vous avoir vous avez d'abord
lancé une opération de sauvetage le
président de la république a proposé des
alliances texte par tex ou un
gouvernement d'union nationale mais il
ne s'agit surtout pas pour lui d'
infléchir son programme de maltraitance
sociale et d'irresponsabilité écologique
non puisqu'il a reçu dit il une
légitimité clair sur le fondement d'un
projet clair là encore vous refaites
l'histoire emmanuel macron n'a pas été
élu par adhésion à son projet
il a été élu face à l'extrême droite les
citoyens avaient le chantre le pire et
le pire du pire ils ont choisi le pire
malgré tout emmanuel macron ne veut rien
lâcher de son programme impopulaire
dorénavant tout sera comme auparavant
pour lui l'élection législative n'a
jamais eu lieu comme toujours au
maquereau ni l'essentiel est de simuler
la démocratie pour mieux la bafouer le
président afin d'engager les discussions
désormais la balle serait dans le camp
des oppositions il ne nous incomberait à
nous de nous situer par rapport au parti
majoritaire qui n'est à présent plus
majoritaire en d'autres termes soit nous
avalisons la guerre sociale la retraite
à 65 ans et le conditionnement du rsa au
travail gratuit soit nous sommes une
minorité de blocage soit nous sommes de
votre côté c'est à dire contre le peuple
soit nous sommes pour l'intérêt général
donc pour vous hors du champ républicain
votre ministre de l'intérieur nous
désigne comme des ennemis là encore vous
avez en horaire tout ce qui s'apparente
à une opposition démocratique et fait
vivre l'alternative dans ce pays ce sera
donc vous le déluge dites vous nous
disons que quand c'est vous c'est le
chaos nous savons que pour vous depuis
si longtemps la terre ne tournait pas
autour du soleil mais autour de jupiter
en vérité la macro ni peine à faire le
deuil des cinq années passées elle
traîne une nostalgie enfantine les
playmobil lui manque qu'il était 10e
temps où 300 députés a ployé de concert
sur un bouton sans prendre le temps de
lire les textes le pouvoir est désormais
en disgrâce impropre à la démocratie
alors la macro nice se replie sur elle
même elle grogne elle boude ses pulsions
d'éviction du show républicains lui
reprenne le sectarisme me revient au
galop hors de question de signer la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle de
la nuit baisse visant à protéger le
droit à l'avortement le pouvoir minorité
à fera sa propre proposition même si
elle n'est inscrite nulle part à l'ordre
du jour de cette session peut-être parce
que vous avez préféré mettre ce texte au
placard pour acheter la complaisance du
rassemblement national
il va falloir vous y faire
vous n'êtes plus le centre de gravité
politique
vous êtes battus
après tout pourquoi nous ferions vous
confiance madame ou bornes il faut le
dire vous êtes une rescapée vous êtes la
première ministre la moins bien élu de
la vème république
vous avez maintenu un gouvernement a
troué assure 6 3 devant ministres ont
été défaits aux législatives la ministe
des autres maires a tenu trente six
jours avant de prendre la fuite que dire
du ministre accusé de plusieurs de vos
gueules maintenu en poste jusqu'à lundi
ou de celles visées pour des viols
gynécologique toujours en fonction à ce
jour le camoufler électorale des
législatives porte votre nom mais vous
voilà toujours là un gouvernement
chaotique en succès d'un autre vous
promouvez les amis qu'ils vous restent
rares sont ceux qui veulent monter à
bord du titanic alors l'équipe des
volontaires ressemble à s'y méprendre à
un fonds de tiroir dans ce gouvernement
d'harmoniser on croise des hommes
essentiellement aux ministres contre
cinq femmes en revanche un homme
secrétaire d'état contre neuf femmes
renaissance a par ailleurs réfuté la
manif pour tous le ministère de la
jeunesse et sous la tutelle du ministère
des armées les outre-mers dépendent de
l'intérieur peut-être comme récompense
de l'envoi du gign et du raid en
guadeloupe la planification écologique a
disparu au profit d'un ministère piloté
par un novice votre nouveau monde est
une machine à remonter le temps
pourquoi nous ferions view confiance
avoue qu'ils découvraient les profiteurs
de guerre mais ne fait rien quand ton
talent grange 16 milliards de bénéfices
vous qui présentait des mesures sociales
inférieures au niveau de l'inflation
vous à nouveau épinglée par le haut
conseil pour le climat pour votre
inaction climatique vous qui ne fait
confiance qu'aux riches et aux pollueurs
vous qui n'avez rien fait pour enrayer
la crise des urgences et des
établissements de santé dans le pays
nous ne vous faisons pas confiance mais
en font peu vous chaud madame la
première ministre soyons clairs croyez
vous que notre modèle de production et
de consommation doivent bifurqué pour
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
nous oui vous non croyez vous que le
marché les incantations soit en
incapacité de régler tous les problèmes
nous oui vous ne trouvez vous indigne
que 10 millions de personnes vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté quand cinq
milliardaire possède autant que 27
millions de français nous oui vous non
que cela vous plaise ou non il va
falloir vous y habituer
cela s'appelle la démocratie
madame la première ministre il faudra
vous soumettre ou vous des maîtres nous
ne croyons pas une seule seconde à une
ma chronique qui retrouve la raison vous
avez présenté votre feuille de route
celle du dépôt de bilan de monsieur
emmanuel macron voici la nôtre de
feuille de route cette semaine nous
avons présenté notre deuxième
proposition de loi commune à la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
smic à 1500 euros nets blocage des prix
à la baisse des produits de première
nécessité et du carburant
revalorisation de 10% des aides au
logement et du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
garantie d'autonomie à 1063 euros par
mois pour les jeunes
augmentation de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire des conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé gel des
loyers voilà des mesures qui seraient de
nature à débloquer le pays car la
minorité de blocage à la vie digne à la
redistribution des richesses à la
sauvegarde de nos écosystèmes
c'est vous
[Musique]
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
le président marc l'ex pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues les
français ont décidé en élisant leur
député à l'assemblée nationale de priver
le président de la république de
majorité absolue notre assemblée
aujourd'hui à l'image de notre pays
fracturé avoir voulu dissoudre des
clivages politiques par des débauchages
individuels
north a consisté au final qu'à remettre
au goût du jour la vieille recette de la
petite soupe sur le petit réchaud
dénoncé en son temps par le général de
gaulle mais n'aura pas permis de relever
le défi essentiel enrayer le déclin de
la france cette petite soupe nous n'en
voulons pas notre responsabilité claire
ni compromission ni petits arrangements
avec un président de la république dont
nous contestons les orientations
chancelante depuis 2010 est sur la dette
sur l'énergie sur la souveraineté
agricoles et industriels sur la sécurité
sur l'immigration sur la transition
écologique mais jamais de blocage
stérile nous n'avons pas l'intention de
tous paralysés alors que notre pays a
déjà pris 30 ans de retard faute d'une
vision claire et d'une action résolue
nous ferons tout pour que les cinq
prochaines années soit plus utile à
notre nation que l'ont été les 10
dernières nous avons pour boussole le
bien commun de la france et des français
dès qu il en sera question nous serons
au rendez vous oui nous sommes prêts à
voter tous les textes qui est rond dans
le sens du sursaut national celui du
pouvoir d'achat par le travail de la
reconstruction de notre appareil
industriel de la sanction des
délinquants ou de l'accès à la santé
mais pour que la france retrouve la
maîtrise de son destin nous vous
engageons madame la première ministre à
une franche rupture avec la politique du
chien crevé au fil de l'eau il est temps
de répondre à l' attente légitime
d'autorité dans notre pays l'autorité du
savoir et de l'enseignant à l'école
d'autorité des policiers dans nos
quartiers d'autorité de la loi et de la
sanction vis-à-vis des délinquants
d'autorité de nos frontières face à des
flux migratoires qui déborde nos
capacités d'assimilation
l'humiliation qu'a représenté pour les
français la chienlit du stade de france
est un énième symptômes de l'alarmante
déliquescence de l'autorité dans notre
pays nous vous appelons en prendre la
mesure et à prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent
si vous êtes disposé à construire assez
de places de prison nettement plus que
les 2000 places supplémentaires de la
dernière mandature vous pouvez compter
sur nous si vous êtes disposé instaurer
des peines minimales exemplaires ou
enfin sanctionné les délinquants vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à plafonner strictement
l'immigration en fonction de nos
capacités d'amis d'assimilation vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à expulser les étrangers fiché
pour radicalisation terroristes vous
pouvez compter sur nous
nous devons sûr aussi et peut-être
surtout répondre à cette exigence de
justice sociale la plus élémentaire
pouvoir vivre dignement de son travail à
coups de shaka crédit de dépenses
sociales incontrôlée vous avez fait
croire que l'assistanat était la
solution alors qu'il n'est qu'illusion
plutôt que de multiplier les chèques
d'argent public tâchant de réduire
l'écart délirant entre le salaire brut
et le salaire net en réduisant les
prélèvements obligatoires dont nous
sommes les champions
plutôt que de réduire les retraites
fruit d'une vie de travail par leur sous
valorisation ou la hausse de la csg et y
est enfin de courage de mener une
réforme juste de notre système de
retraite oui nous devons tout faire pour
revaloriser le travail et il n'y a pas
de droit son devoir si vous êtes prêts à
exiger des bénéficiaires du rsa 15
heures d'activité par exemple dans nos
ehpad qui manque ne serait ce que deux
présences humaines auprès de nos aînés
alors vous pouvez compter sur nous ne
nous dupont pas la clé du pouvoir
d'achat est là que la france produisent
plus d'emplois et plus de richesses
alors ne tuons pas ce qui reste d'un dut
ce cri d'industrie au nom d'un
écologisme punitif dont le seul effet
est de produire plus à l'écran
désormais la majorité de notre empreinte
carbone nous tuions à la fois nos
emplois et notre planète pour créer les
conditions d'une réindustrialisation
carbonée il faut moins de normes moins
de paperasse et une vraie politique de
filières et il nous faut surtout et il
nous faut surtout madame le premier
ministre retrouver l'excellence
nucléaire sans laquelle l'électricité
sera plus chère et plus dé carbonée que
de temps perdu
renationaliser edf pourquoi pas si ça
n'est pas pour mieux le démembrer
nationaliser les pertes pour privatiser
les profits ça ne peut pas être ça le
projet
enfin arrêtons arrêtons d'être les
idiots du village planétaire toutes les
nations défendent leurs intérêts y
compris au sein de l'union européenne
personne ne défendra les nôtres à notre
place et nous devons enfin sortir de
l'illusion de l'argent magique qui
menace notre souveraineté la réalité se
rappelle déjà à nous au terme d'un
mandat qui a augmenté de 700 milliards
la dette publique deux fois plus qu en
allemagne est nettement moins en raison
de la crise sanitaire qu'en raison de
vos choix budgétaires comme l'a rappelé
la cour des comptes
nous voilà nous voilà aujourd'hui au
pied du mur avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt alors revenons au bon sens de
montesquieu la politique fondamentale le
point fondamental de la bonne
administration est simple il ne consiste
qu'à ajuster la dépense avec la recette
tous les entrepreneurs doivent le faire
toutes les familles doivent le faire
votre gouvernement doit aussi le faire
madame la première ministre est là
dessus votre discours nous laisse
interrogatif
les familles et les entreprises
françaises sont toujours aussi accablé
d'impôts et de taxes le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires est le même en
2021 qu'il était en 2016 alors que notre
hôpital est au bord de l'implosion que
le niveau de notre éducation s'effondre
et qu'elle ne prend même plus assez le
mérite que la justice ne sanctionne trop
peu et trop lentement et qui est 2
millions de français sont privés d'accès
à la santé
seul l'argent du contribuable trop
souvent gaspillée la réalité est là il
est possible et nécessaire de faire
mieux avec moins d'argent public soyons
clair augmenter les effectifs de
soignants ou de magistrats oui mais à
condition par ailleurs de réduire
drastiquement les emplois publics dans
les administrations centrales d'en finir
avec cette bureaucratie tatillonne dans
les quelques 1200 agences de l'état dans
tous ses bureaux qui ont pullulé à
mesure que les services de terrain se
raréfiaient la méthode de la révision
générale des politiques publiques d'il
ya 15 ans n'était peut-être pas la bonne
mais cela ne justice in ne justifie en
rien de laisser filer le nombre
d'emplois publics comme vous le faites
depuis 2010 cette soixante dix mille
emplois supplémentaires dans la seule
faction public faire des économies
d'argent public est possible comme nous
le démontrons dans les régions dont nous
avons la charge
et il faudra et il faudra enfin avoir le
courage de protéger l'argent des
français tout autant contre la fraude
sociale que contre les champions de
l'optimisation fiscale qui abusent sous
vos yeux sous les yeux de bercy de prix
de transfert pour ne pas payer d'impôts
en france nous serons à vos côtés si
vous avez le courage de réduire la
dépense publique est efficace pour
réduire l'imposition confiscatoire du
travail y compris madame le premier
ministre l'imposition des moyens d'aller
au travail c'est à dire des carburants
la taxation des carburants c'est le plus
injuste des impôts parce que c'est
l'impôt qui visent directement et
exclusivement cette france qui se lève
tôt pour bosser qui ne s'en sort plus
cette politique du courage que nous
appelons de nos voeux et la seule apte à
rétablir la cohésion nationale
autour du terme de ces cinq années notre
nation est épuisée fracturée les
français ont envoyé un message au
président de la république
l'arrogance solitaire et le mépris des
corps intermédiaires doit cesser au
cours des cinq prochaines années
l'assemblée des élus de la nation que
nous sommes que nous sommes tous devra
être devraient être entendus et nous les
députés républicains nous avons un
combat celui de la cohésion nationale
la cohésion nationale ce n'est pas un
slogan tiède et vaporeux comme l'est
devenu le vivre ensemble c'est un
inlassable combat animé par l'amour de
la france qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'y
ait pas une france des précaires et une
france des protégés mais une seule
france qu'il n'y ait pas une france des
jeunes et une france des seniors mais
une seule france qu'il n'y ait pas une
franche des métropoles une france des
villages mais une seule france qui n'est
pas une france des usines une frange de
start up mais une seule france qu'il n'y
ait pas une france qui croient au ciel
une france qui n'y croit pas mais une
seule france la france fière de son
histoire est sûr de son destin notre
nation n'est ni un taureau d'individus
nine juste à position de communauté elle
est ce que nous avons en héritage en
partage elle nous dépasse nous oblige
non seulement nous avons le droit mais
nous avons le devoir de défendre notre
nation et notre mode de vie oui nous
voulons que la france reste la france
que notre nation retrouve son rang voilà
le chemin exigeant sur lequel vous savez
pouvoir nous trouver
j'en ai ressources
la parole est au président mattei pour
le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre chers collègues
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure madame la
première ministre nous sommes face à une
situation exceptionnelle et à des défis
immenses
une situation exceptionnelle d'abord par
la composition de notre assemblée le
peuple français à travers les élections
légistatives vient de faire de la
proportionnelle une réalité le groupe
démocrates attachés à l'idée d'une
représentation proportionnelle salue la
proposition notre présidente donc créé
ce principe dans le marbre de la loi au
cours de cette législature
de fait le parlement reflète davantage
aujourd'hui la société française dans la
diversité de ses opinions et de ses
attentes
loin d'être un signe d'instabilité
c'est une preuve de la vitalité intacte
de notre démocratie
cela nous oblige à réinventer notre
façon de travailler ensemble chacun
d'entre nous est à sa place ici celle à
laquelle l'a hissé le suffrage universel
avec les idées qu'ils incarnent chacun
chacun a ici la lourde responsabilité
de façonner le destin de la france et
des français pour les cinq prochaines
années le parlement sera plus que jamais
au coeur de la vie politique et
institutionnelle
c'est un motif de satisfaction pour
notre famille politique
montesquieu que j'ai cités également
nous a appris que pour qu'on ne puisse
abuser du pouvoir il faut que par sa
disposition même le pouvoir arrête le
pouvoir
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 a
fait sien cet objectif et à donner
davantage de droits aux parlements dans
l'initiative et le contrôle législatif
elle a reconnu les droits de
l'opposition dont la présidence de la
commission des finances elle était
inspirée par l'inquiétude démocratique
d'un parlement qui ne refléteraient plus
l'opinion ou muselle ray l'opposition au
point que celle-ci n'aurait d'autre
choix que la rue pour se faire entendre
nous avons la chance de disposer nation
soldats socle institutionnel solide qui
permet d'inscrire le changement
politique majeur que nous vivons dans le
cadre existant le parlement devient
désormais incontournable ni une chambre
d'enregistrement ni un récif sur lequel
se brise toutes les réformes ou toutes
les idées
il nous faudra revoir notre façon de
légiférer et de travailler ensemble
entre nous d'abord et avec le
gouvernement aussi dans un dialogue
constructif permettant d'aboutir à des
accords solide car viable dans le temps
et consentis par tous pour cela madame
la première ministre vous me trouverez
toujours à vos côtés en qualité de
médiateur tout comme le groupe démocrate
nous avons élu la semaine dernière pour
la première fois une présidente de
l'assemblée nationale c'est une fierté
pour tous les parlementaires est un
signe incontestable que les mentalités
évoluent nous avons choisi pour la
première fois un député d'un parti qui
n'avait jamais gouverné la tête de la
commission des finances le gouvernement
ainsi remaniée est un gouvernement
d'action au service des français il
devra plus que jamais entendre ce qui se
dira dans notre assemblée et dans le
pays
ses qualités d'écouté de dialogue sont
je le sais les vôtres madame la première
ministre et je salue votre élection en
tant que députée du calvados qui fait de
vous l'une des nôtres aussi vous avez
tout votre légitimité
vous êtes madame la première ministre
une femme d'état aguerris et je sais que
votre connaissance de nos institutions
et du gouvernement vous permettra de
conduire efficacement son action et
d'animer un dialogue vertueux avec le
parlement nous sommes en effet face à
des défis immenses il nous reviendra
ensemble de poursuivre les réformes
utiles à notre pays pour lesquels nos
concitoyens ont réélu le président de la
république et pour ce faire il nous
faudra continuer à libérer les énergies
sans casser les talons et réparer la
cohésion de notre société
le groupe démocrate est le premier
soutien de la majorité nous en
partageons les valeurs le respect de
chacun et le souhait d'une société plus
solidaire le goût de la liberté dans une
france apaisée réunis autour du pacte
républicain avec un parlement fort et un
état de droit respecté le souci de voir
nos territoires protégés intégrer à la
république par une décentralisation
efficace maï et des services publics est
entendu dans leurs besoins spécifiques
le désir d'améliorer la vie des gens
dans le respect de l'état de droit de
moderniser l'économie
d'encourager les entrepreneurs et de
soutenir les plus fragiles contre les
chocs qui déstabilise la société la
volonté de répondre à l'urgence
climatique et préserver notre
environnement nous le devons aux
générations futures le haut conseil pour
le climat évalue l'augmentation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 6
4% depuis l'an dernier malgré une baisse
tendancielle de 23% par rapport à 1990
signe de l'importance de cette prise de
conscience au plus haut sommet de l'état
vous êtes madame la première ministre en
charge de la planification écologique
énergétique et vous avez déjà annoncé
nouvelle loi de programmation pour le
climat début 2000 23 c'est pourquoi ne
soutiendront au groupe démocrate
le programme ambitieux proposé par le
président de la république en matière
d'action climatique nous attacherons
avec vous à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 à rénover 700 mille
bâtiments à végétaliser les villes à
consacrer 10 milliards la transition
écologique sur le quinquennat
la défense de notre souveraineté
nationale aussi bien militaires que
stratégique énergétique et alimentaire
passe par une armée forte la
modernisation du modèle industriel et
agricole et le développement du mixte
énergétique
l'appartenance européenne qui nous
permet d'être plus forts ensemble sur la
scène internationale dans un contexte
qui a révélé la fragilité la fragilité
des états isolé à ce titre nous pouvons
nous réjouir que nos partenaires et
écouter la voix la france au cours des
six derniers mois de présidence
française de l'union européenne
sur la scène internationale
la france a également oeuvré pour
avancer sur les questions climatiques le
mois dernier le jeu c'est a repris
l'engagement de mettre un terme au
financement des énergies fossiles sans
capture de carbone d'ici la fin de
l'année 2022
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république
l'accord de paris a été réaffirmée il
vise à limiter le réchauffement
climatique à
1,5 pour cent par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle et à parvenir à zéro
émissions nettes carbone d'ici 2050 nous
aurons enfin l'impérieuse nécessité de
restaurer nos finances publiques très
dégradées pour ne pas léguer un avenir
hypothéqué à nos enfants sur ce point
nous devrons préserver les moyens de
l'état à faire face à une autre crise
majeure les réponses ponctuelles et
d'urgence ont été adaptés à la queue
ville 19 elles ont impliqué une
dégradation considérable de la dette
l'état emprunte aujourd'hui à 2% ce qui
entraînera une augmentation de 11 points
de pib de la dette en dix ans revenir à
une maîtrise réelle de nos finances
est une obligation pas une option nous
devrons réfléchir aux solutions pérennes
qui permettront de re trouver un point
d'équilibré viable pour l'économie et la
société
le monde change la france change la
société change notre pays divisé notre
devoir de tout faire pour réunir nos
concitoyens cela nous oblige à un plus
grand devoir de solidarité et de
responsabilité
la crise nous a montré la fragilité de
notre société d etat face aux crises
chacun d'entre nous l'a ressentie à son
propre niveau du retraité à l'étudiant
du chef d'entreprise aux salariés nous
devons donc renforcer notre capacité à
répondre à une nouvelle crise tout en
restaurant le moyen de résilience
collectif à l'heure où l'inflation
aurait fait sur l'apparition frôlé les
6% sur l'année alors que les économistes
la croyait disparue à jamais nous devons
travailler en premier lieu sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat
pour nos concitoyens pour que chacun
puisse raisonnablement se projeter dans
l'avenir sans brider ni briser les
talons nous devrons repenser la
fiscalité pour mieux répartir les
richesses et garantir l'accès aux
ressources naturelles et énergétiques
dans la rareté nous a été cruellement
rappelé nous devrons être collectivement
plus vertueux plus sobre plus économes
dans nos façons de vivre de consommer de
nous déplacer
nous devrons aussi accepté d'aborder
sans tabou la question du vieillissement
la société et ce qu'elle implique en
termes de cinquième risque
et de viabilité de notre système de
retraites ne pas le faire serait là
encore trahir les générations futures
nous vivons un contexte international de
montée des périls qui a déjà marqué de
son browser delà de l'histoire de notre
pays avec la guerre à nos portes en
europe dans l'eau l'horreur saisi chacun
de nous de nous nous nous devons tout
faire pour que la france se soit pas
déstabiliser et affronter aussi les
enjeux de la solidarité et de notre
tradition d'accueil désormais posée de
façon inédite les français ont besoin de
notre sagesse pas de posture politique
ou d'un hatem madame la première
ministre
madame la première ministre le groupe
démocrate demeurera un soutien un
partenaire engagé à la fois au parlement
et dans votre gouvernement il sera le
laboratoire des pratiques nouvelles de
votre majorité
nous savons votre détermination nous
savons votre courage votre pugnacité
vous connaissez notre fidélité fidélité
notre soutien constructif c'est pourquoi
sur ce chemin vous avez toute notre
confiance je vous remercie
la parole est au président va l'eau pour
le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la première ministre madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues voici donc
réunis dans l'un de ces moments
singuliers dont l'histoire a parfois la
ruse un moment singulier est à bien des
égards inquiétant singulier d'abord car
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
le parlement trouve aujourd'hui une
centralité nouvelle le suffrage
universel notre juger notre maître à
tous madame la première ministre nous a
pas accordé de majorité les français ne
vous font plus confiance ils ne font
plus confiance au président de la
république et ne veulent pas de son
programme vous avez perdu le président
absolue en même temps que vous perdiez
la majorité absolue les électeurs ont
donc fait le choix d'une minorité
présidentielle et d'un parlementarisme
de fait le coeur du pouvoir a quitté le
palais de l'elysée pour prendre place
ici au palais bourbon
inquiétant ensuite car cette assemblée
est la plus mal élue de son histoire sa
légitimité mise à mal par la même
raymond tente de l'abstention symptôme
d'une démocratie fatiguée et d'électeurs
qui ne croient plus en leurs
représentants
inquiétant surtout avec l'entrée en
nombre d' une extrême droite dont vous
aviez promis d'être le rempart et au
lieu de cela nous avons entendu dans vos
rangs même se fissurer le front
républicain sur vous quand même facilité
l'élection de deux vice présidents du
rassemblement national la fébrilité une
excuse ni de perdre son sang froid ni
ses principes républicains je le dis
pour nous il n'y a rien à espérer du
désespoir et l'extrême droite est une
funeste impasse dans cette assemblée
comme socialiste comme républicains nous
serviront toujours une autre idée de la
france madame la première ministre ne
vous rejoindront pas pour mettre en
oeuvre un programme et un projet
libéraux qui ne sont pas les nôtres et
pour lesquels les électeurs ne nous ont
pas désigné nous sommes opposés durant
cinq ans à la baisse des appels à
l'abandon de la sf et à l'institution
d'un flat tax et nous avons plaidé pour
une lutte déterminée contre les
inégalités que vous n'avez en définitive
jamais menée
avons combattu votre réforme de
l'assurance-chômage violente avec les
plus précaires du logement social
désastreuses pour les bailleurs sociaux
combattu encore votre première réforme
des retraites injuste aux métiers
pénibles nous avons dénoncé les
insuffisances de votre engagement en
faveur de l'environnement qui vous a
valu d'être condamné pour une action
climatique nous avons dénoncé le
malthusianisme de votre politique
éducative guide et non par l'ambition de
donner une place à chacun mais par le
souci que chacun reste à sa place
nous sommes des solidarités et d'autres
politiques en matière d'asile et
d'immigration et avant contester les
lois qui portait une atteinte excessive
à nos droits et nos libertés à chaque
fois à chaque fois nous avons proposé à
chaque fois vous êtes obstiné madame la
première ministre convenait avec nous
nous n'avons pas été élus pour donner au
président la république la majorité que
les françaises lui ont refusé moins
encore pour mettre en oeuvre la retraite
à 65 ans les contreparties au rsa ou la
libérer de gestion de l'école publique
13 millions de français sont en
situation de précarité de mobilité 12
millions habitent dans des passoires
énergétiques 10 millions vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté 8 millions vivent dans
un désert médical 6 millions demeure
sans emploi stable
trois cent mille sont sans domicile fixe
et 20% de nos compatriotes vivent à
découvert la température augmente en
même temps que la biodiversité
s'effondre et nous avons touché les
limites du monde tel qu'il a prévalu
aujourd'hui menacé par l'injustice et la
démesure et en définitive par la
précarité économique sociale écologique
où nous a entraînés l'ère néolibérale
vous inspirer un retour à la normale
nous aspirons un changement de modèle à
l'aube d'une décennie critique nous
avons des propositions utiles à la vie
des françaises et des français et nous
sommes prêts à en débattre ici notre
projet ne nous appartient pas l'idéal
qu'il entend porter est à la portée de
tous chaque fois que vous élevez vous
élèverez le débat pour atteindre l'idéal
de justice vous trouverez à vos côtés
vous affirmer que les oppositions
s'oppose à tout alors apprenez à écouter
à considérer leur proposition est
parfois allé faire vôtre nous défendons
le travail de valeur et la
reconnaissance de l'utilité sociale
chacun doit pouvoir vivre de la dignité
de son travail un travail de qualité
justement rémunérés notre philosophie
n'est pas celle des chèques occasionnels
et des primes qui ne crée pas de droits
sociaux mais celle des salaires qui
permettent de vivre de son travail est
de préparer sa retraite du juste partage
de la valeur ajoutée voilà pourquoi nous
proposons le smic à 1500 euros et la
limitation des écarts de rémunération
nous proposons une plus grande justice
fiscale pour que les classes moyennes
cesse de payer les impôts des riches que
vous avez exonéré dsf pour que les pme
et les pmi cesse de payer les impôts que
les multinationales cache dans les
paradis fiscaux nous proposons
l'ouverture des droits sociaux à 18 ans
comme partout en europe car nous ne
voulons plus voir notre jeunesse grossir
les rangs des banques alimentaires
jaurès disait que la république est un
grand acte de conscience de confiance eh
bien faisons confiance à notre jeunesse
nul besoin de la placer sous la tutelle
du ministère de la défense comme vous le
proposez aujourd'hui
nous proposons une politique écologique
et sociale du logement et la
massification de la rénovation thermique
des logements pour sortir en disant les
français de la précarité énergétique une
écologie populaire planifié plutôt que
l'effondrement brutal pour permettre aux
français de mieux vivre de bien se loger
de mieux se nourrir de mieux se déplacer
de pieux habité nous défendre la
république jusqu'au bout celle de jaurès
celle des services publics nous
défendons l'accès aux soins par
l'obligation d'installation des médecins
par la différence de l'hôpital nous
défendons l'accès à l'éducation par la
mixité scolaire que vous n'avez jamais
défendu ses prisons comme bien d'autres
nous les avons formulé elles sont
aujourd'hui sur la table c'est le sens
de la proposition pour le pouvoir
d'achat que nous avons déposé avec la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale
il va vous falloir écouter entendre
renoncer à beaucoup de vos projets alors
que je vous paraissez d'avoir renoncé à
rien à partager aussi le pouvoir pour
l'exercer à faire vivre ce parlement
président du groupe socialiste et
apparentés je suis le dépositaire d'une
grande famille celle du socialisme qui
siège sur ses bancs de l'assemblée
nationale depuis 129 en or en me
retournant sur cette histoire je
constate que certains des grands combats
qu'on menait le socialisme qui font
désormais partie de notre histoire
commune l'ont été alors que les
socialistes ne disposez pas de majorité
je prendrai deux exemples le début de la
4è république à quelques titres de
gloire
l'application du programme du cnr la
fermeture du bagne de cayenne la
nationalisation des banques et des
industries de l'énergie
le retour à la semaine de 40 heures la
généralisation de la sécurité sociale or
ce fut une majorité allant de la
démocratie chrétienne jusqu aux
communistes en passant par les
socialistes qui présida à cette oeuvre
une majorité qui donna sa confiance
aussi bien un socialiste comme félix
gouin qu'un démocrate chrétien comme
georges bidault mon deuxième exemple
remonte à la fin du 19ème d'une
troisième république fatigué ou se
succéder les scandales et les affaires
jusqu'aux plus grands périls l'affairé
dreyfus la république était en danger en
1899 après une énième provocation
nationaliste au plus fort de la crise le
gouvernement waldeck-rousseau obtient la
confiance d'une large à partie de
l'assemblée qui allait du centre droit
jusqu aux troupes de jaurès or ce
gouvernement sera le plus long de la
troisième république c'est celui qui
mettra fin à la terre dreyfus c'est
celui qui en sera le travail des femmes
et des enfants celui qui permettra le
loi des sous sur les associations
l'internationalisation des
fonctionnaires et c'est toujours avec le
soutien de la gauche et les socialistes
que cette assemblée vota l'immortel
séparation des églises et de l'état
vous le voyez si j'osais je dirais que
la république ce que la république a
réalisé de plus glorieux elle l'a fait
dans la diversité des formations
politiques je veux m'adresser
aux députés du rassemblement national un
instant l'histoire glorieuse que je
rappelle ici n'est pas la vôtre
ce dont vous êtes les héritiers n'était
pas dans les murs de cette enceinte en
1946 je le dire je n'ose dire où ils
étaient pour la plupart ce dont vous
êtes les héritiers était en revanche sur
le banc des accusés de zola ce que la
france a fait de grands dans son
histoire elle l'a fait le plus souvent
sans vous et le plus souvent elle l'a
fait contre vous
venons en madame la première ministre à
ce parlementarisme de fait
madame la première ministre partage et
la maîtrise de l'ordre du jour en
mettant l'agenda législatif de votre
gouvernement
au sein de la conférence des présidents
de l'assemblée nationale
rééquilibrer l'initiative de la loi en
intégrant dans votre agenda les
propositions parlementaires en
particulier celle des oppositions à nous
de les défendre desserrer l'étreinte du
temps sur les travaux parlementaires en
allongeant de quelques semaines le délai
entre le dépôt de vos textes et le
moment on en discutera laisser le temps
à des travaux préparatoires de qualité à
des délibérations sincère à la recherche
de l'intérêt général retenez vous
d'utiliser les procédures d'urgence et
les ordonnances fait cela madame la
ministre changer
quitte à légiférer un peu moins et chers
collègues
pratiquons différemment notre mandat
répartissons mieux la fonction de
rapporteur de nos travaux entre nous
exigions de celle d'esso qui exerceront
ce travail de concertation de travailler
avec tous les groupes investissent l'ont
pleinement la fonction de rapporteur
d'applications pour juger de la qualité
des études d'impact donnons ainsi une
utilité aux contributions citoyennes
déposés à l'occasion de celle ci un
jardin 17e titre partagé initiative
législative 4 et quart équilibré merci
beaucoup je termine terme et temps
législatif
exercice nouveau des fonctions de
rapporteur socialiste de gauche nous
demeurons votre opposition n'est
désaccord sont nombreux profond nous
défendrons a sonné la justice et
l'égalité je termine non merci mr
motorisés enfin enfin merci mais c'est
la même règle pour tout le monde le tube
halo c'est simplement la même règle pour
tout le monde merci beaucoup
mais là
la parole est à mme au président marc
angeli pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente
madame la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est avec la conviction que
nous vivons un instant particulier est
décisif notre vie démocratique et
institutionnel que je m'adresse à vous
au nom du groupe horizon et apparentés
que j'ai l'honneur de présider
la tâche qui attend notre assemblée
nationale est considérable si le
contexte politique dans lequel nous nous
trouvons est inédit c'est avec un
nécessaire recul qu'il nous faut
l'appréhender le choix des français nous
oblige nous parlementaires à prendre un
tournant majeur dans notre manière de
légiférer au nom du peuple français
madame la première ministre les rapports
que votre gouvernement entretiendra avec
cet hémicycle devront tenir compte du
vote dont sont issus les 560 députés de
la nation
non la france n'est pas devenue
ingouvernable
nous demeurons convaincus que si les
femmes et les hommes de bonne volonté
s'organise et s'entendent au service de
l'intérêt national
alors nous ferons de cette nouvelle
configuration une force
les élus locaux que nous sommes pour bon
nombre ici font quotidiennement cet
exercice du dépassement au sein de leur
collectivité
puissions-nous nous remémorer nos
expériences et nous inspirer des
méthodes de gouvernance locale
indispensable dans nos territoires
désormais requise au coeur de notre
hémicycle
notre responsabilité collective face au
destin de notre pays mérite bien que
nous nous essayons à l'exercice
incommode mais pas insurmontable du
consensus notre pays trace sa voie dans
un monde incertain et dangereux la
guerre est de retour sur le continent
européen
nos soldats donnent leur vie pour
combattre le terrorisme islamiste et je
voudrais ici leur rendre hommage notre
situation
économique devient chaque jour plus
périlleuse et pèse sur notre dette
publique trop nombreux sont nos
concitoyens qui souffre d'un pouvoir
d'achat indigne dans un contexte
d'inflation galopante
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'europe est menacée et les événements
climatiques extrêmes se multiplient et
pour finir malheureusement la pandémie
menace à nouveau en ces temps de grands
bouleversements la france court le
risque de se retrouver en marge des
affaires du monde nous courons mes chers
collègues le risque de la vulnérabilité
ce sentiment de vertige ce sentiment de
doute sur notre destin national est au
fond à l'origine de l'inquiétude du
peuple français il nous appartient à
nous responsables politiques législateur
membres du gouvernement de les
réconcilier avec la politique
pendant cinq ans beaucoup a été fait par
le président de la république et les
gouvernements d'edouard philippe et jean
castex pour tenir le cap d'une france
plus forte plus juste et plus prospère
mais ce bilan n'altère en rien notre
conscience de l'ampleur des changements
et transition dont le pays s'impatiente
c'est dans cet esprit de continuité que
le groupe horizon s'est engagé au sein
de la majorité présidentielle qui doit
désormais devenir une association de
projets et d'actions pour continuer à
réformer le pays
ce projet de réforme porté par le
président de la république
qu'on le veuille ou non a été validé par
les français
le au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
mais en choisissant leurs députés les
français ont aussi adressé leurs
responsables politiques un message rare
dans l'histoire de notre vème république
aucun groupe n'est en mesure de
gouverner seul le dialogue la recherche
du compromis et l'air large issement de
la majorité sont donc les seuls façon de
conjurer l'immobilisme nous avons
aujourd'hui la lourde responsabilité de
répondre à l'appel des français mes
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement que nous dit
cet appel il nous dit d'abord agi ses
réformes et protéger libérer appliquées
dans ces grands dîners sa philosophie le
projet que nous avons choisie lors de
l'élection du président de la république
mais en même temps il nous dit
travailler ensemble
soyez créatifs et raisonnable tirer le
meilleur de chaque proposition pour agir
sur l'essentiel cesser les postures et
les effets de manche dont nous ne
voulons plus mes chers collègues
ce message envoyé par le peuple français
nous allons devoir nous en accommoder
certes nous entendons les appels au
dialogue texte par texte c'est ce que le
bon sens politique semble commander mais
le coup par coup ne propose pas de
stratégie pérenne mûri car considérer
les choses par le petit bout de la
lorgnette n'a jamais produit une ligne
claire de gouvernement essaie bien de
ligne claire dont le pays a aujourd'hui
besoin nous sommes convaincus que le
projet précède l'alliance nous croyons
que les convergences sont possibles
notre devoir de parlementaire consiste à
identifier ces convergences à les
exposer clairement aux français et à
agir en conséquence nous le disons très
nettement proposer aux français une
plate forme d'actions communes ne
signifie pas gommer les différences ont
abandonné les identités politiques c'est
se mettre d'accord sur l'essentiel sur
les dispositions concrètes factuelle qui
nous permettront de répondre à la fois
aux défis les plus urgents comme à ceux
des générations à venir nous croyons au
groupe horizon et apparentés que la
majorité ait d'autres forces peuvent
s'accorder sur quelques piliers
d'actions simples de bon sens et proche
des préoccupations de notre peuple
d'abord
la priorité donnée à l'éducation c'est
la mère de toutes les batailles il
existe déjà un consensus politique dans
cette assemblée pour porter l'effort sur
les fondamentaux le français et les
mathématiques pour revaloriser la
rémunération et le rôle des professeurs
améliorer l'orientation des élèves vous
donner plus de liberté aux
établissements pour mener à bien leur
projet pédagogique
prendre des mesures en faveur de
l'éducation nationale c'est aussi plus
largement s'inquiéter des conditions de
vie et d'éveil de nos enfants du
harcèlement à l'école aux violences
intrafamiliales de la lutte contre la
grande précarité à celle des
discriminations de toutes formes notre
groupe donnera la priorité à ces
urgences de notre siècle aggravée par la
recrudescence des contenus toxiques en
ligne dans le même temps nous devrons
travailler sans relâche sur les
problématiques reliées à la santé à
l'autonomie au grand âge ainsi qu'à
l'émergence d'une société plus inclusive
pour nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap
ensuite il nous faut préserver notre
souveraineté budgétaire et financière
notre dette publique se chiffre à 2008
113 milliards d'euros soit près de 120 %
de notre pib
cela doit nous alerter
et nous sommes nombreux à souhaiter que
notre état soit plus économe et
reviennent sur une trajectoire
financière soutenable nous sommes mes
chers collègues que nous le voulions ou
non l'assemblée nationale qui devra
accompagner la sortie du quoi qu'il en
coûte indispensable en son temps et
restaurer l'équilibré de nos comptes
publics
nous le savons et nous le savons tous il
en va de notre indépendance nationale et
de la pérennité de notre modèle social
français les français attendent aussi de
nous une france plus sûre sur tout le
territoire de la république nous
trouverons une majorité pour mettre plus
de forces de l'ordre sur le terrain et
opérer un effort de recrutement massif
dans la justice nous devrons travailler
à la simplification des procédures pour
mieux punir les infractions du quotidien
et les violences à l'égard des
dépositaires de l'autorité publique nous
devrons consolider les bases d'une
écologie le gouvernement fondée sur le
progrès la justice sociale la sobriété
la protection de notre biodiversité et
sa durabilité
dans toutes nos réformes nous sommes
certains que nous atteindrons un
compromis lorsqu'il s'agira de répondre
à ces enjeux fondamentaux et mettre
notre pays sur la voie d'une société
sobre et prospère assurer notre
prospérité c'est aussi restaurer les
bases de notre puissance économique et
industriel c'est la france du travail
c'est une france compétitive et
innovante
pour cela il faut poursuivre la
modernisation de notre code du travail
et la réforme de l'assurance chômage
aller plus loin dans la baisse des
impôts de production pour les
entreprises nous devons atteindre
l'objectif d'un million d'ha trappe
d'apprentis parents et réformer le lycée
professionnel
enfin
nous considérons que la préservation de
notre modèle social passe par une
réforme de notre système de retraite par
répartition pour le rendre plus sûr plus
juste et plus fluide nous le savons
pour leur rendre soutenable ce système
sans augmenter les cotisations des
actifs ni baisser les pensions des
retraités
la question de l'âge de la dette du
départ à la retraite doit être posée les
modalités notamment de prise en compte
de la pénibilité la fixation d'une
pension minimale et la sortie des
régimes spéciaux doivent faire l'objet
de discussions large mais à nouveau il
nous faudra trouver la voie de la
concorde et du compromis sur ce sujet
éducation santé ordre public sérieux
budgétaire écologie
solidité notre modèle social risques
liés à la vie hyper connectés ses
piliers peuvent constituer les sens
d'une majorité parlementaire d'action
pour faire des cinq années qui viennent
un succès pour la france ces pays ne
sont pas exhaustifs nous pouvons
également nous retrouver sur bien
d'autres sujets et surtout ses enjeux
nous devons nous appuyer sur les élus
locaux et leur faire confiance pour ma
part madame la première miss je voudrais
clairement vous dire que nous serons à
vos côtés et vous dire en tant qu'élu de
la corse suite aux propos que vous avez
tenus tout à l'heure que je serai
également avec mes trois collègues que
je salue à vos côtés pour faire en sorte
que nous le territoire dont je suis
issue vivre des lendemains meilleurs
comme le disait winston churchill mieux
vaut prendre le changement par la main
avant qu'il ne nous prennent par la
gorge soyons les artisans de bonne
volonté ce changement politique dans le
pays a besoin le groupe horizon il
prendra toute sa part
père réussit à la mosson coup vous
pouvez compter sur nous madame le
premier ministre merci
merci beaucoup
la paroisse l'état madame cyrielle
châteaulin pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente sheila
pour cinq minutes c'est cela
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement chers collègues
43 degrés à biarritz le 18 juin 51
degrés à jacobabad le 14 mai le 14 mai
au pakistan chaque année nous
connaissons de nouveaux records de
température l'action humaine notre
action modifie le climat met en péril le
vivant nous sommes entrés dans l'ère de
l'anthropocène il n'y a plus de rage
mais des tempêtes plus d'épisodes
pluvieux mais des inondations les
sinistres succèdent aux catastrophes les
classes ferment padovese face aux vagues
de chaleur ici comme ailleurs
régulièrement les récoltes sont perdues
les bâtiments détruits les routes
défoncées les arbres arrachés et bien
souvent il ya des morts
pourtant nous savions depuis longtemps
en 1971 total en terre un rapport sur
l'impact de ses activités sur le
réchauffement climatique en 1984 le
rapport met dos explique pour la
première fois d'une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini n'a pas de sens
depuis 1988
les experts du giec alerte les
gouvernements nous ne faisons rien
disons le clairement la transition
écologique n'est toujours pas le coeur
des politiques publiques je vous le dis
plus clairement encore madame la
première ministre votre projet à 50 ans
de retard il est tout droit sorti des
années 70 la période où la croissance la
technologie et l'énergie infinie devait
résoudre tous les problèmes en cinq ans
la situation s'est dégradée il est là
votre bilan la certitude que faute d'une
action déterminée faute de choix clair
et assumé faute d'un budget à la hauteur
la france trahi les engagements de la
coop 21 dont nous étions si fiers
pourquoi cette inaction parce que
certains se pense à l'abri croient
encore que l'argent leurs traits mais de
s'adapter de créer une bulle de confort
illusion paré pour l'effort par et pour
les puissants
pourquoi cet attentisme parce que les
premières victimes du dérèglement
climatique sont les plus pauvres les
plus vulnérables abl ceux qui ne vivent
pas au bon endroit celle qu'on entend
rarement qu'on ne veut pas écouter qu'on
ne voit pas ce qui croule sous les
factures sous les contraintes et sous
l'inflation celles qui tiennent aux
hôpitaux à bout de bras quand elle fait
face à une pandémie n'est de la
destruction des milieux naturels
pourquoi cet immobilisme parce que
l'écologie madame la première ministre
est une promesse de campagne sitôt trahi
au lendemain des élections
pour affronter la crise climatique il
voit à compter les inégalités
territoriales
vous en avez parlé madame la première
ministre mais comment vous croire chez
moi en isère la montagne s'écroule les
glaciers disparaissent les étés sont
irrespirable à la luire alain
villeneuvois renaudie on est tous sur
les dalles l'été et on gèle l'hiver dans
les passoires thermiques pour affronter
l'effondrement du vivant il faut oser
remettre en cause un modèle économique
l'idée par une idéologie productiviste
extractiviste est destructrice lanuf s
est une union des forces parce que pour
nous il est évident que la lutte contre
les dérèglements climatiques est un
combat pour la justice sociale
lorsqu'on est comptable d'avis l'an tels
que le vote madame la première ministre
je comprends que vous ne vous soumettiez
pas un vote de confiance car la
confiance d'un second quinquennat se
construit et se délite sur l'épreuve
laissé par le précédent
l'épreuve ne joue pas en votre faveur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage un recul
social la baisse des apl une ponction
directe chez nos bailleurs sociaux
l'enterrement de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat une erreur historique
pensez vous vraiment qu'il suffira de
quelques effets de manche pour que notre
pays aille mieux quand c'est tout un
système qui broie des vies entières les
français les françaises n'y crois pas
écoutez les les gilets jaunes et les
matchs pour le climat ont convergé pour
ne rappeler que la fin du monde et la
fin du mois sont un seul et même combat
les électeurs et les électrices ont fait
un choix le choix de vous imposer dans
les urnes la proportionnelle que vous
leur aviez promis sont jamais là leurs
données ils ont eu raison ils ont eu
raison avant de l'institution ils ont eu
raison avant un personnel politique
fossilisé dans son présidentialisme ce
vote vous oblige madame la première
ministre après nous avoir expliqué ils
vous obligent à écouter à écouter
l'assemblée nationale à écouter le
peuple n'ayez pas peur de l'année où
cratie n'ayez pas peur de cette
assemblée faites confiance aux français
et aux françaises qui portait déjà les
prémices ils n'ont pas fonction vivent
une autre attention aux mondiaux de
cette assemblée soit c'est l'outil
seront des chemins pour une nouvelle
sensibilité aux vivants pour
l'émancipation de chacun et de chacune
et pour conserver l'habitabilité de
notre terre merci beaucoup
la parole est au président chassaigne
pour le groupe la gauche démocrate et
républicain nombre
à
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre sheikh collègues vous n'avez
pas dans cet hémicycle a semblé que vous
espériez votre formation politique et
vos alliés ne forment plus qu'une
majorité relative très relative cette
déroute d'un président de la république
privé de majorité absolue n'est pas un
accident de parcours elle est d'abord
l'expression du rejet massif de la
méthode de gouvernement qui a prévalu
sous le précédent quinquennat
l'hypertrophie
présidentielle a vécu le chef de l'état
ne peut donc affirmer que les français
lui ont renouvelé leur confiance sur le
fondement d'un projet clair et en lui
donnant une légitimité clair il n'a pas
de mandat pour imposer son agenda
politique
l'heure n'est plus à l'exercice
solitaire du pouvoir
l'heure n'est plus à l'arrogance et au
mépris des revendications populaires
elle n'est plus au passage en force à
l'humiliation du parlement aux pouvoirs
exorbitants des cabinets de conseil qui
considèrent les êtres humains comme des
agrégats statistiques et comme des
chiffres à gérer la démocratie enfin
retrouve des couleurs et vous allez
devoir apprendre à écouter à dialoguer à
respecter la représentation nationale
est adopté une attitude constructive
vous avez par ailleurs devant vous une
assemblée divisée à l'image de notre
pays que vous avez contribué à fracturer
tout en faisant grandir la peste brune
votre politique de défaisance sociale
conduite avec acharnement à attiser la
colère de nos concitoyens qui assiste à
l'effondrement de notre système de santé
au dépeçage dans le système éducatif au
recul des services publics à la
dégradation de l'environnement et de
leurs conditions de vie à présent il
ploie sous la hausse de l'inflation
tirés par les prix de l'énergie des
matières premières vous répondez comment
leurs difficultés en multipliant les
rustines en accumulant les petits
chèques et des mesures d'urgence
inefficace et sans lendemain comment
pourrait-il en être autrement car le
chef de l'état a fixé pour ligne rouge
de l'augmenter ni les impôts ni la dette
comme dans davos gouverneur
l'immobilisme des lanternes du
quinquennat vous n'avez les mains libres
que pour reprendre d'une main ce que
vous donnez de l'autre pour opérer des
coupes sombres dans les dépenses
publiques et pour détricoter notre
système de protection sociale et de
retraite
nous n'acceptons pas cette politique du
pire qui conjugue injustices sociales
précarité inaction climatique recul du
service public nous récusons
l'arbitraire de ces fameuses lignes
rouges nous avons une exigence
revoir de fond en comble notre système
fiscal pour garantir une meilleure
répartition des richesses et de la
valeur
réduire les écarts de revenus
pénaliser la rente financière améliorée
significativement le niveau de vie de
l'immense majorité dans le concitoyen
mettre en oeuvre ce que préconise l abbé
pierre le contraire de la misère ce
n'est pas la richesse le contraire de la
misère c'est le partage
nous devons aussi
remettra en cause des règles budgétaires
européennes pour recréer un état qui
planifient et investit dans la
transition écologique dans notre système
éducatif sacrifié dans la restauration
de notre système de soins dans l'extrême
dégradation tétanise notre peuple à
l'aube de cet été que tous les
professionnels de santé prédisent comme
dramatique à raison du manque de
personnel l'autre urgence est de
revaloriser de manière significative et
pérenne les salaires les pensions et les
minima sociaux mais aussi de bloquer le
prix des loyers des carburants de
l'énergie
de telles mesures
répondent non seulement une attente de
nos concitoyens
mais ils nécessitaient économique
l'enjeu de favoriser l'accès de tous à
une alimentation et à des biens plus
durable et de meilleure qualité
l'urgence est enfin en matière
internationale de promouvoir la paix
cela passe en europe par la résolution
des causes profondes du conflit
craignant nous ne créerons pas les
conditions d'une sécurité civile
collective européenne
sans remettre en cause la manière dont
celle ci a été construite 100 euros
désarmement sans nous appuyer sur l'oeil
nu et le respect du droit international
la même exigence
la même exigence vaut pour le proche et
le moyen-orient et le conflit israélo
palestinien
nous le dirons jamais assez la france
doit jouer un rôle moteur au plan
diplomatique pour récuser les deux poids
deux mesures et ouvrait en toute
souveraineté à la coopération solidaire
des nations et des peuples
il nous a pas échappé par ailleurs que
le groupe j'ai l'honneur de présider est
celui qui accueille en son sein le plus
grand nombre de parlementaires
d'outre-mer des parlementaires
décidé à faire entendre leur voix une
voix singulière qui va vous falloir le
aussi apprendre à écouter respecter sur
ces territoires la situation est
gravissime se nourrir se loger se
soigner
se déplacer tout est déjà plus étaient
déjà plus cher avant la crise désormais
les shows coûts explosent au mono pour
les diots paul qui résiste aux lourdes
amendes s'ajoute le fret maritime dont
les tarifs ne semble plus avoir de
limites
aucun secteur n'est épargné les prix des
matières premières flambent les
consommateurs trinquent souvent cité
comme un exemple à suivre
le bouclier qualité prix de la réunion
qui limite les prix des produits de
première nécessité est lui même menacé
puisque des industriels locaux en
demande la révision
davantage encore que dans les autres
territoires oubliés de la république
nombreux sont nos citoyens d'outre-mer
qui survivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
l'inflation amplifiera ses ravages si
des mesures fortes ne sont pas prises
sans plus attendre la revalorisation du
coefficient géographique est devenue une
urgence et ne peut plus à nouveau être
reporté
dans ce contexte le développement des
circuits courts et l'objectif
d'autonomie alimentaire sont partout
partout préconisé mais aussi entravé
bien déterrée antillaises sont polluées
pour des siècles par ce scandale d'état
de l'utilisation massive de la
chlordécone
tandis tandis que le statut du foncier
en guyane a interdit tout développement
d'initiatives locales connaissez vous un
autre territoire de la république où 95%
du foie du foncier relève du patrimoine
de l'état ou un agriculteur où un
industriel
un maire est confronté un foncier
abondant mais rendu rare est cher par
cet anachronisme
juridico-politique ces territoires ne
doivent plus être placé à la périphérie
c'est pourquoi nous continuerons à
porter aussi la voix du peuple